[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معاكم في دباسيل
وفي عناوين الحصاده
في اليوم الثالث عشر لكارثه السيول بدء
عمليات اغاثه المنكوبين جوا غربي ليبيا
استمرار عمليه انتشار الجثث في البحر
وجهود مكثفه لفتح الطرق المؤديه للمناطق
المنكوبه
وفي المغرب الحكومه تعلن فتح كل الطرق
المتضرره وتقول انها ستطلق برامج تنميه
جديده في المناطق المنكوبه
القرم في مرمى الاستهداف الاوكراني لليوم
الثاني السلطات الروسيه تعلن تصديها لهجوم
صاروخيا على مرفع
كاف تعلن مقتل شخصيات قياديه بالهجوم على
الاسطول الروسي
يقول ان الغرب يخوض قتالا مباشرا ضد روسيا
في اوكرانيا
على وقع معارك مستمره في الخرطوم رئيس
مجلس السياده السوداني يحذر في تصريحات
للجزيره من توسع الصراع الى خارج البلاد
يقول انه بحث في لقاء مع البرهان ما وصفه
بالنشاطات غير القانونيه للمجموعات
المسلحه المموله من روسيا
[موسيقى]
تستمر فرق البحث والانتشار في عملها
بمدينه درنا الليبيه للعثور على جثث
الضحايا سواء في المدينه او تلك التي
جرفتها السيول التفاصيل في التقرير التالي
لا يمكن تقديم رقم دقيق لعدد الضحايا او
المفقودين جراء عاصفه دانيال ومات لها من
سيول الجارفه المعلوم ان الفريق المسؤول
عن البحث عن ناجين في دارنا انها مهمه
بمرور عشره ايام وبالتالي تراجعت اي فرص
بالعثور على احياء
وبغياب اي ارقام مؤكده تحسن منظمه الصحه
العالميه حتى الان اكثر من 4000 وفاه في
درنه بينما لا يزال اكثر من ثمانيه الاف
شخص في عداد المفقودين والارقام مرشحه
للارتفاع التحدي حاليا يكمن في اخراج جثه
الضحايا ودون ذلك عقبات كثيره اهمها ضعف
المعدات التقنيه الخاصه بالكشف عن مواقع
الجثث برا وبحرا
في المدينه تبحث فرق الانقاذ عن الضحايا
في الابنيه المنهاره والمناطق التي غمرتها
المياه والطم وما جرفه السيل في طريقه
ولهذا الغرض يتم غالبا اللجوء الى اساسيات
الحفر والتنقيب اليدوي وتدخل اليات غير
ثقيله وكلاب مدربه على تحديد مواقع
الضحايا وبعد الاعلان عن انهاء عمل فرق
الانقاذ تتحول الى فرق بحث وانتشال حيث
يمكن ادخال معدات ثقيله والحاجه في درنا
تتمحور حول معدات اكثر تطورا والتي يمكن
ان تستخدم لرصد الاحياء وجثث الضحايا
كتقنيه ليدار التي ترتبط باقمار صناعيه
تربط بجهاز الملاحه جي بي اس وكاميرا
فوقيه ترسل اشارات للقمر الصناعي بما
تتلقاه من معلومات بعد بث نبضات ليزر
للبحث عن احياء او ضحايا
كما تحتاج فرق البحث الى تعزيز قدراتها
على البحث عن جثه الضحايا التي جرفتها
السيول الى البحر وهذا يعني الحاجه لفراق
غطس متخصصه باستخراج الضحايا وزوارق قادره
على تنفيذ عمليه بحث وانتشال والعوده الى
الشواطئ وفي حاله درنا العوده الى شواطئ
يتراكم فيها الحطام
وتتبدل الصعوبات اللوجستيه في التعامل مع
الناجين ايضا حيث نفذت السلطات عمليه
اغاثه جويه لسكان منطقه وادي الناقه غربيه
درنه وتقدر السلطات ان 80% من البنيه
التحتيه وخمسين في المئه من الطرق تضررت
بفعل الكارثه
قال محمد الجارح الناطق باسم لجنه الطوارئ
التابعه للحكومه المكلفه من مجلس النواب
ان اجماليه عدد الوفيات في المناطق
المتضرره من السيول التي ضربت مناطق شرق
ليبيا بلغ
3,845 واضاف الجارح في مؤتمر صحفي في
بنغازي ان النائب العام شكل لجنتين
للابلاغ عن المفقودين في درنه والمناطق
المتضرره موجهه نداء الى اهالي المفقودين
لتسجيل محاضر الابلاغ عن ذويهما
النائب العام بتشكيل لجنه لجنه لعمليه
الحصر والتوثيق الخاصه بالتعريف عن
المفقودين وتم تشكيل فريقين رقم واحد او
المنطقه الاولى هي في منطقه شيحه الغربيه
في مقر الخدمات الضمانيه والثاني في منطقه
باب طبرق في مقر الخدمات الصحيه
ويعني نوجه نداء لكل من لديه مفقود من اهل
مدينه درنه وايضا المناطق المتضرره في
انهم هم يذهبوا ويقوموا بعمليه الابلاغ عن
المفقودين في النقطتين هذه
ينضموا الينا من بنغازي محمد سعيد الرفلي
المتحدث باسم الهيئه الليبيه للاغاثه
والمساعدات الانسانيه سيد محمد ما هي ابرز
التحديات التي تواجه عمليات الاغاثه بدايه
فيما يتعلق بالاغاثه اذ تقصدين المساعدات
الانسانيه جهود مستمره من فرق العمل
بالاغاثه سواء كان الهلال الاحمر ليبيا او
الهيئه الليبيه اللي غاثه ومساعدات
الانسانيه او الاوقاف لتقديمها لمستحقيها
سواء كان داخل مدينه دارنا الذي تم فيها
تجهيز مخزن استراتيجي متكامل لتوفير
المتطلبات المعيشيه وايضا متطلبات
الايوائيه ومتطلبات الاهتمام بالاضافه
الشخصيه وايضا بعض السلع المعمره
للمواطنين في هذه المنطقه نعم كيف تصلون
الى المنكوبين يعني عندما تتحدث السلطات
عن ان 80% من البنيه التحتيه مدمره وخمسين
بالمئه من الطرقات كيف تتجاوزون هذه
الصعوبات
نعم هذه الصعوبات حيث قامت لجنه العمار
وايضا بالتنسيق مع القوات المسلحه في
انشاء طرق بديله للطرق المنهاره من خلال
انشاء طرق بديله تقوم بتوفير خدمات التنقل
للمواصلات وايضا لعربات النقل عبر هذه
الطرق الجديده بعد ان تم تجفيف مصادر
المياه المختلفه التي كانت سببا في غرق
العديد من الطرقات وذلك سعيا لايصال
الخدمات للمواطنين وايضا فتح المجال امام
المواطنين للتنقل من مدينه الى اخرى ومن
قريه الى اخرى من خلال هذه الطرق الترابيه
وفي ذات الوقت تم ربط الان مدينه ادارنا
شرقها بغربها من خلال جسر سيكون مؤقتا
للتنقل بين شطري المدينه حيث كان في
السابق انتقال من غرب الى شرق دارنا يتطلب
السفر لمسافه قدرها كيلو متر هذه الاعمال
والانجازات التي تقوم بها لجنه الاعمار
بشكل سريع هي الهدف منها هي سرعه تقديم
الخدمات وايضا سرعه اتاحه الفرصه ايضا حتى
امام رجال الانقاذ والقوات المسلحه
والدفاع المدني والاسعاف للتنقل بشكل ميسر
سعيا نعم على سبيل المثال وادي الناقه تم
يعني القاء المساعدات جوا عن طريق الجو ما
قدره الحكومه الليبيه على التوسع في هذا
الاطار لتشمل مناطق اخرى كواد الناقه
نعم وادي الناقه هي منطقه محاصره بالمياه
وعدد من المواطنين داخل هذه المنطقه في
اطار دعمهم ورفع من معاناتهم من خلال
القوات المسلحه تم نقل هذه المساعدات جوا
باستخدام طائرات الهليكوبتر لمستحقيها في
هذه المنطقه التي تعتبر منطقه وعره نوعا
ما لانها منطقه وادي وصعب الدخول اليها
بالاليات والمركبات العاديه حتى تتم او
حتى تنشف المياه بشكل بشكل جيد وايضا تضاف
لها الطرق بديله للطرق التي انهارت في هذه
المنطقه فصعوبه التنقل كان لزام على
القوات المسلحه ان تتطوع في هذا الجانب
وتنقل هذه المساعدات بالتنسيق مع غرفه
الطوارئ الرئيسيه بدرنه السؤال كان عن
قدرات الحكومه الليبيه للتوسع في هذا
المجال هل هي قادره على تغطيه مناطق اخرى
بنفس الطريقه بنفس الطريقه عفوا
نعم هو اغلب المناطق الان ماهيش مناطق
محاصره هي وادي الناقه فقط اللي يعتبر
محاصر المناطق الاخرى قوات الجيش ولجنه
العمار قامت بفتح مسارات وطرق بديله للطرق
المنهاره وتم فيها تقديم الخدمات اليوم
عشرات البلديات من المناطق المنكوبه تم
نقل المساعدات اليها اليوم وامس واول امس
في اطار رفع المعاناه عن هذه الاسر وقدرات
الجيش وايضا وصول مساعدات مختلفه سواء كان
وجود القوات المصريه والله ايضا وصول حتى
المساعدات التركيه في هذا الشان تساهم
جميعها في دعم هذا المجال فيما يتعلق
بانشاء
مراكز طبيه او مستشفيات ميدانيه تقوم
بالخدمات في هذا الجانب مسانده لليبيا بعد
الاستجابه لهم لمطالب الحكومه في التدخل
في مساعده الليبين محمد سعيد الورفلي
المتحدث باسم الهيئه اللي بيه للاغاثه
والمساعدات الانسانيه شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
الى تداعيات زلزال الحوز في المغرب حيث
تتواصلوا عمليه احصاء المنازل المتضرره في
المناطق المنكوبه جراء الزلزال الذي ضرب
منطقه الحوز الشهر الجاري بالتزامن مع
عمليات الاغاثه التي ينفذها الجيش المغربي
في المنطقه وتواصل اللجان التقنيه
المغربيه في الاقاليم المنكوبه احصاء الاف
المباني المتضرره وقد اكد رئيس الحكومه
المغربيه عزيز اخنوش ان الحكومه ستطلق
برامج تنميه جديده في المناطق المنكوبه
وقالت وزاره الاقتصاد والمنيه المغربيه
انه سيتم استحداث وكاله ستشرف على برنامج
اعاده بناء المناطق المتضرره من زلزال
الحوز الذي خصص له مبلغ اثني عشر مليار
دولار على مدى خمس سنوات اضافت وزاره
الاقتصاد والماليه المغربيه ان عمل
الوكاله سيكون مؤقتا ومرتبطا بمده برنامج
اعاده وبناء المناطق المتضرره وستقوم
بتتبع صرف المساعدات وانجاز مشاريع اعاده
البناء والتاهيل بالاضافه الى تنسيق بين
مختلف القطاعات وتنفيذ مشاريع التنميه
[تصفيق]
في الاثناء قال مسؤولون في بلديه مراكش
للجزيره ان نسبه الانتهاء من عمليه ايواء
المنكوبين المتضررين من الزلزال في مراكش
بلغت نحو
95% بينما تجاوزت نسبه انجاز عمليه
الاحصاء للمنازل المنكوبه 50% بالمدينه
القديمه وبحث مسؤولو البلديه وبحسب
مسؤوليه البلديه فان قرارات الهدم جاهزه
وستهدم كل المنازل التي تضررت كليا واعاده
بناء مساكن جديده من ناحيه اخرى تحولت
قاعات رياضيه في مدينه مراكش الى ماوى
لمئات الاسر التي تعرضت منازلها لاضرار
ينضم الينا من مراكش مراسل جزيره المختار
العلاوي المختار نتابع معك عمليات الاغاثه
ومساعده المنكوبين واعاده بناء المساكن
نعم فدا تتم هذه العمليات على عده مستويات
ويتم عمليا اجراءات المخطط الاستعجالي
القاضي باعاده الايواء واعاده الاعمار
وهذا المخطط الذي رسلت له اثني عشر مليار
دولار ستكون ايضا من بنيه التحديات قضيه
التمويل ولهذا تقول السلطات المغربيه ان
التمويل هذا المشروع الكبير سيكون من
الموازنه العامه للدوله ومن الجماعات
المحليه وايضا من التعاون الدولي ودعم
الدول الشقيقه لماذا لان هذا المشروع
الكبير 12 مليار دولار سيستهدف اعاده بناء
المناطق المتضرره والقيام واطلاق العديد
من المشاريع الخاصه بهذه المناطق المتضرره
من اجل مواكبتها اقتصاديا خصوصا وانها
تضررت بشكل كبير اقتصاديا بالاضافه الى
تضرر البنايات في هذا السياق يتم عمليه
احصاء ومراقبه المباني الاله للسقوط في
شيشاوه في ازيلال في تارودانت في ورزازات
وفي مراكش عملت مراكش واقليم الحوز الاكثر
تضررا باعتباره هو مركز الزلزال هذه
العمليه تتواصل لحد الان نلاحظ السلطات
التقنيه برفقه السلطات المحليه تقوم
بمعاينه المنازل وتسجيل البيانات وتحديد
طبيعه الانهيار لان طبيعه الانهيار الجزئي
او الكلي هو الذي سيحدد طبيعه الدعم الذي
ستتلقاه الاسره المغربيه وهنا قال رئيس
الحكومه المغربيه عزيز اخنوش انه يتمنى ان
يتم ان يتم عمليه التعويض المتضررين في
اقرب وقت مباشره بعد انتهاء عمليه
مراقبه المنازل هنا في مدينه مراكش
السلطات قالت لنا انها تقريبا انهت 50% من
المنازل المتضرره في المدينه القديمه
لوحدها والمدينه القديمه لوحدها في مراكش
تضررت بشكل كبير بالنظر الى البناء
التاريخي الموجود في هذه المنطقه زمنيا
يبقى الاسبوع القادم للانتهاء من عمليه
حصر المنازل وهي العمليه التي مباشره
ستليها عمليه التعويض ايضا هناك تعويض
للاسره المتضرره يصل الى 250 دولار في
المجمل 3000 دولار لكل اسره 12 شهرا هذا
التعويض سيساهم في التخفيف من الاسر التي
فقدت مصدر رزقها بالنظر الى ان بعض المهن
توقفت خصوصا في الحوز هو ايضا اقليم
يستقطب السياح والكثير من اصحاب المهن
اصحاب المحلات التجاريه المهن الحره هؤلاء
تضرروا وبالتالي الدوله تريد ان تساعد
وتساهم بتعويضات ماليه لهؤلاء في سياق اخر
ايضا هناك عمليه اطلقتها وزاره التعليم
العالي الهادفه الى تدعيم الطلبه
ومواكبتهم خلال هذه المرحله وتقدير
اجراءات سهله بالنظر الى انها مفتقدوا
الكثير من الوثائق الرسميه خلال هذا
الزلزال المختار العلوي مراسل الجزيره من
مراكش
[موسيقى]
الى حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا حيث تعرضت شبه
جزيره القرم لهجوم صاروخي والثاني من نوع
خلال 24 ساعه وقد اعلن الحاكم الروسي
لمدينه سافاستوبول ان الدفاعات الجويه
تصدت لهجوم صاروخيا سقط حطامه في مرفا
المدينه بينما اعلن الجيش الاوكراني انه
هجومه على مقر الاسطول البحريه الروسي في
القرم امس استهدف اجتماعا لقاده في
البحريه الروسيه ما ادى الى مقتل عدد
منهما
[موسيقى]
لم يجب الدخان عن سماء سيفاستوبول حتى عاد
من جديد للمره الثانيه خلال 24 ساعه تتعرض
المدينه جنوبيه القرم لهجوم اوكراني يقول
حاكم المدينه الروسيه ان الدفاعات الجويه
تصدت لهجوم صاروخي سقط حطامه في مرفا
المدينه كالامس تعلق حركه نقل الركاب في
خليج سيفاستبول ففي الامس تقول القوات
الاوكرانيه انها استهدفت اجتماعا لقياده
البحريه الروسيه ما ادى الى مقتل تسعه من
القاده العسكريين الروس في المدينه كانت
موسكو قد اكدت حينها ان جنديا واحدا فقط
قتل في الهجوم اذا استهدفت كييف مقر اسطول
البحر الاسود الروسي وذلك اسطول يتبع
للبحريه الروسيه ووظيفته تامين الحدود
الجنوبيه لروسيا كما يملك قطعا عسكريه
بحريه متنوعه تعزز الوجود العسكريه
الروسيه في بحري ازوف والاسود وهما بحراني
تنطلق منهما العمليات العسكريه الروسيه في
المناطق الجنوبيه من اوكرانيا سواء
بالصواريخ التي تطلق من القطع البحريه
هناك او بالامداد اللوجستيه للقوات البريه
في شبه جزيره القرم منطلق الهجمات الروسيه
في الجبهه الجنوبيه هكذا تتحول القرن
وسباسبول تحديدا الى مركز استراتيجي
لروسيا سياسيا وعسكريا وهدف استراتيجيا
لاوكرانيا عسكريا باضعاف خط الامداد
الرئيسي في المنطقه الجنوبيه للروس
وسياسيا بالتاكيد على احقيه كييف بضرب
اراضيها المحتله كما تقول منذ عام 2014
غير بعيد عن القرم والسباستيوبول
الاستراتيجيه يتواصل القتال على خطوط
التماس الجنوبيه هناك تسعى القوات
الاوكرانيه بكل قوتها الى تحقيق اختراق
حقيقي نحو القرم من الجهه الشماليه تستهدف
مدينه ميلوتوبول الواقعه على خط القطار
الرئيسي من زبولوجي ان حول القرم تقول تلك
القوات انها الحقت خسائر فادحه في الجيش
الروسي هناك غير بعيد عن زبروجيا تقول
القوات الروسيه انها قتلت اربعه الاف جندي
اوكراني على خطوط الجبهه هناك خلال
الاسبوع الماضي بالاضافه الى تدمير
مخزونات الصواريخ المجنحه وقذائف
اليورانيوم المنظم التي استلمتها كييف من
الغرب هكذا يؤكد كل طرف على روايته في ضرب
الاخر وتحقيق التقدم لكن الاعين الان
تتركز على القرم لتكون مسرح العمليات
الاوكرانيه المكثفه قبل الشتاء
انضموا
الينايف محلل للشؤون السياسيه والعسكريه
كما ينضم الينا من موسكو بافل الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي سيد بيتر ما الهدف
من التكرار العمليات في شبه جزيره القرم
يعني اكثر من ضربه خلال 24 ساعه
في هذه العمليات تاثير نفسي كبير من خلال
ضرب شبه جزيره القرم لانها مكان مقدس
لبلاديمير بوتر لانها ارض اوكرانيه ضمها
في 2014 مما زاد من شعبيته في صفوف شعبه
والان الشبه جزيره القرم تبين ضعفا وهشاشه
وضعفا هشاشه في دفاعات روسيا الجويه هناك
اسباب عمليه لان مركز قياده عمليات
الاسطول في البحر الاسود الروسي تم ضربه
يوم امس وقيل ان هناك عددا من كبار الضباط
حتى ربما احدا برتبه جنرال اما قتل او جرح
اذا هذا له اهميته ايضا ضربه اليوم على
اسطول البحر الاسود هذا يخدم هدف تقليل
قدره روسيا اوكرانيا من شبه جزيره القرم
وان يسمح من خلال اضعاف قوه الاسطول
الروسيه لاستئنافي صادرات القمح
الاوكرانيه لان روسيا فرضت حصان على ذلك
وعلى اوكرانيا ان تبقى على قيد الحياه
اقتصاديا وتحتاج لذلك لتصدير القمح سيد
بابل تتكرر الهجمات على شبه جزيره القرم
ولا تبدو بان روسيا قادره على وقفها
لا يوجد اي دفاع جوي ضد الطائرات ضد
الصواريخ يكون قادرا على اداء مهمته بشكل
كامل حتى البعض من افضل الانظمه تم
اختراقها من خلال هذه الضربات ولا يمكن
روسيا ان تحمي نفسها من كل الهجمات من
الجزء الغربي من القرن القريب من الشواطئ
والمناطق الاوكرانيه نعم هذه
تقدم دعما نفسيا كبيرا للمؤسسه العسكريه
الاوكرانيه اما من حيث تاثير هذا الضربات
على الجبهات جبهات القلال في مازق كلا
الجانبين يضربوا ويستخدموا
باسلحه معياريه عميقا في اراضي العدو
شبه جزيره القرم تعطي ايضا ميزه اضافيه
للاوكرانيين لانها تعتبر في الغرب ليست
ارضا روسيه وهذا يعني ان استخدام اسلحه
غربيه بعيده المدى التي قدمها الغرب
لاوكرانيا مثل الصواريخ
شادو وصواريخ كروز الشبحيه يمكن ان تستخدم
بشكل مبرر ضد اهداف شبه جزيره القرم ومن
خلال هذا وايضا باستخدام صواريخ اوكرانيه
صنع محليه الصنع بعيده المدى بينما
يعني اشرت الى اكثر من نقطه اسمع من السيد
بيتر سيد بيتر ما واجهت الربط بين هذه
الهجمات المتكرره على شبه جزيره القرم
وعدم تحقيق نجاحات في الهجوم المضاد
الاوكراني
الانتقادات بما في ذلك من مصادر غربيه
وخبراء غربيون هم ايضا من اصدقائك يقولون
انه اوكرانيا تشتت انتباهها وعليها ان
تركز على
الهجوم
المضاد وفي تقارير صدرت عن مراكز بحثيه
تقول ان هذه الهجمات مبرره لانها تضعف
قدراتي روسيا في استخدام شبه جزيره القرم
لاعاده تجهيز قواتها في الجنوب واوكرانيا
حاولوا تصعيد هجماتها في الجنوب لقطع
امدادات الجيش الروسي لذلك انا اعتقد ان
المسالتين مرتبطتين
اوكرانيا ستكون في النهايه ناجحه ودعم
كبير للهجوم المبارك بان
يقوم به كيافه في جزيره القرم ما هو الا
للتغطيه على عدم قدرتها على تحقيق انجازات
في هجومها المضاد
انا سمعت هذه النقطه نعم
واليوم ونحن نتحدث الان
تفيد بان اوكرانيا ربما
حررتوفا في الجانب قد تبدو هذه مكاسب
صغيره قريه بعد قريه لكن اوكرانيا توسعوا
من نطاق المناطق التي تحررها وتحاول وصول
الى كتله حرجه بوصول الى مدينه توكماك
وعند ذاك سوف تسيطر ناريا ومن خلال ذلك
تضع كل القوات او خطوط الروسيه في مرمى
نيرانها وبذلك ستساعد جهدها الحربي بشكل
كبير سيد بابل يعني قللت من شان الهجمات
التي تقوم بها الجهات الاوكرانيه على شبه
جزيره القرم ولكن هي استهدفت
جيسكريتش قاعده سيفا ستوبول مقر اسطول
البحر الاسود الروسي انها لا تبدو هذه
الاهداف استراتيجيه ومهمه ووصلت اليها
اوكرانيا
نتيجه هذه الهجمات على الاغلب
نفسيه تاثير نفسي طبعا له ايضا اهميه كذلك
وهو نوع من التفكير لنا لنتذكر ما حدث في
الثمانينيات في الحرب من العراق وايران
وطبعا ما يحدث الان في
الجبهات هناك نوع من الاشتباك الدموي الذي
انتهى الى مازق
وفي الثمانينيات كانت هناك حرب المدن الان
روسيا ايضا تهاجم في عمق المدن الاوكرانيه
وتستخدم تشكيل واسعه من الاسلحه لكن
لا تستطيع استخدام الطائرات لان الطائرات
لا تستطيع التحليق في الاراضي الاوكرانيه
اوكرانيا من جانبها حصلت على نوع كبير من
بعيده المدى بعضها محليه وبعضها من الغرب
وهي ايضا تضرب هذا ايضا بحد ذاته يتحول
الى شيء من
المازقان يضرب اهداف
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجيه عذرا على
المقاطعه
نشكر ايضا السيد بيتر زلمايافا محلل
الشؤون السياسيه والعسكريه
الروسيه الدول الغربيه بخوض قتال مباشر ضد
روسيا في اوكرانيا وفي كلمه امام الجمعيه
العامه للامم المتحده انتقد لافراف
التعامل الغربي مع مسالتي تمدد الناتو
شرقا والضمانات الامنيه التي طالبت بها
بلاده
القيادات الغربيه لم تحترم وعودها بشان
عدم توسيع حلف شمال الاطلسي شرقا باتجاه
حدود روسيا وفي عام 2021 رفضت مقترحاتنا
بشان ضمانات امنيه متبادله دون تغيير وضع
اوكرانيا كدوله غير منحازه واستمر الغرب
في تسليح نظام كييف المعادل روسيا
وطلب وزير الخارجات الروسي باعاده النظر
في اسس انشاء الامم المتحده والعمل على
توسيع مجلس الامن يخرج من هيمنه الغرب وفق
قوله
ان الحاجه متزايده لتوسيع مجلس الامن
وتعزيز تمثيله لاخراجه من هيمنه الغرب يجب
اعاده النظر في القواعد التي تاسست عليها
الامم المتحده عقب الحرب العالميه الثانيه
لقد حان الوقت الاعتماد اليه منصفه لتشكيل
امانه المنظمه الدوليه واذا لم ترد واشنطن
وحلفائها التفاوض معنا بشان نظام عالمي
اكثر عداله فسنخوض ذلك بانفسنا
[موسيقى]
في تطورات الوضع في السودان تتواصل
المعارك بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع في مناطق مختلفه من العاصمه
الخرطومه فقد افادت مصادر محليه للجزيره
ان الجانبين يتبادلان القذف المدفعي
العنيف بمنطقه جبل اولياء جنوبي العاصمه
وقالت مصادر للجزيره ان الجانبين تبادل
القصف المدفعيه في محيط القياده العامه
للجيش في الوقت نفسه قال مكتب الامم
المتحده لشؤون الانسانيه ان خمسه ملايين
الف انسان غادروا منازلهم في السودان بسبب
القتال المتواصل منذ اكثر من خمسه اشهر
في مقابله مع قناه الجزيره الانجليزيه
اتهم رئيس مجلس السياده بالسودان عبد
الفتاح البرهان قائد قوات الدعم السريع
محمد حمدان حميتي بانه ينكث العهود وقال
البرهان ان الجيش السوداني يلتزم
بالاخلاقيات او باخلاقيات القتال لاسيما
في المناطق الحضريه
هو غير صادق هو من يهاجم الان
النياله هو من يهاجم الجنينه ومن يهاجم
المدن في كل مكان هون يهاجم القوات
المسلحه في مقراته لذلك في جده عندما
توصلنا الى تفاهمات لم يلتزم بها القوات
المسلحه لديها مسؤوليه
دستوريه يا حمايه الامن الدوله هي حمايه
الدوله من الانهيار حمايه الدوله من
التصدع ولذلك تستخدم القوه ضد من يحاول ان
يقوض الامن في الدوله ايضا القوات المسلحه
تلتزم بالقانون الدولي تلتزم بالمعايير
الاخلاقيه في العمليات العسكريه خاصه في
مناطق الحضره وفي المناطق المدنيه
كما قال البرهان للجزيره الانجليزيه انه
سيتم البدء في التحضير لعمليه سياسيه
شامله في السودان تمهيدا لاجراء انتخابات
بمجرد توقف القتال
نحن نعتقد اننا بمجرد توقف القتال او
الوصول الى حلول العمليات العسكريه يبدا
التحضير لعمليه سياسيه شامله
تعيد الاوضاع الاقتصاديه ترتب الاوضاع
الداخليه ثم تعد لانتخابات في نهايه فتره
انتقاليه قصيره نحن نقول ان الشعب
السوداني خرج في ثوره عظيمه في 2019
لديه احلام يريد ان يعيش في حريه وسلام
وعداله القوات المسلحه السودانيه لن تقف
حائلا دون تحقيق طموحات وتطلعاته
واضاف البرهان للجزيره الانجليزيه انما
وصفه بالمجموعات المتمرده اتت من دول
كثيره في الاقليمه وحذر من ان الصراع
سينتقل الى تلك الدول اذا انتهى في
السودان او توسع خارجه
طبعا هذه المجموعات المتمرده اتت من دول
كثيره في الاقليم
لذلك هذا الصراع سينتقل الى تلك الدول
حتما اذا انتهى في السودان او اذا توسع
خارج السودان هنالك مقاتلين من معظم دول
الجوار
وقد بحث الرئيس الاوكراني مع الرئيس مجلس
السياده السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان ما
وصفه زيلينسكي بالانشطه غير القانونيه
للمجموعات المسلحه المموله من روسيا
واعرباز خلال لقائه البرهان في مطار شانن
في ايرلندا عقب مشاركته في اجتماع الجمعيه
العامه للامم المتحده في نيويورك عن
تقديره لموقف السودان الداعم لسياده بلاده
ووحده اراضها كما ناقش الطرفان الممر
البحريه لتصدير الحبوب الاوكرانيه التي
دعز لينسكي البرهان الى دعمه
وينضم الينا في الاستوديو ضياء الدين بلال
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي السوداني سيد ضياء
مثلا هذا اللقاء بين البرهان
عابر وليس له اهميه كبرى ولكن يحاول ان
يستفيد من مثل هذه الاطلالات للتاكيد على
مواقفوا في الحرب
ويحاول ان يحرز بعض المكاسب الدبلوماسيه
عبر هذه اللقاءات لان هذا اللقاء هذا
اللقاء لم يكن مرتب له ضمن اجنده البرهان
في وجوده في الامم المتحده ولكنه تم في
مطار وطالما انه تم في اطار فهو لقاء عابر
حددته الصدفه اكثر من كونه ان هنالك
ترتيبات اختضت
سابقا عن ان القوات الخاصه الاوكرانيه تقف
وراء هجمات نوعيه بطائرات مسيره ضد قوه
الدعم السريع هل ياتي هذا اللقاء ليصب في
مصلحه ما تقولها السي ان ان لا اعتقد ذلك
لانه هنالك في صدر من قبل الجيش بان ذلك
ليس صحيح هو حتى
تلك المعلومه نسبتها الى مصادر مجهوله غير
معلومه ولم تكن لذلك يصبح هنالك شك في صحه
هذه المعلومه وطالما ان هنالك نفي من قبل
الجيش فبالتالي لا يجب ان نحتمد مثل هذه
المعلومات ونؤسس عليها موقفه وقراءه للقاء
من الواضح من حيثيات المكان ومن حيث ياتي
البر انه لقاء تم على سبيل الصدفه العابره
وليس على على سبيل الترتيب المسبق السيد
البرهان تحدث عن عمليه سياسيه ما ان يتوقف
القتال هل هنالك اي تصور لطبيعه وشكل هذه
العمليه السياسيه في حال توقف القتال هذه
العمليه السياسيه كانت يجب ان تتم منذ
فتره وهي عمليه الانتقال تمهيد الاوضاع
للانتقال يتم من خلاله اجراء انتخابات
ولكن نتيجه لمجموعه من العوامل والنتيجه
لمجموعه من المطامع السياسيه تاخر هذا
الامر لان كل الاطراف اطراف مدنيه واطراف
عسكريه لم تكن لها لم يكن لها حرص كبير
على اجراء الانتخابات في تلك الفتره
فبالتالي كان هنالك استثمار سياسي سالب
جديد يعني هل ما كان يجوز سابقا يمكن ان
يطبق الان بعد الذي جرى بين قوات الدعم
السريع والجيش السوداني ربما ذلك هو
الوارد لان هذه التمدد الفتره الانتقاليه
وانزدحام الاجنده لجده الفتره الانتقاليه
بالاجنده العسكريه والاجنده السياسيه
والصراعات هي التي فجرت الاوضاع ولو كان
هنالك ترتيبات كما حدث في كثير من المرات
حتى داخل السودان قال لو كان هنالك
ترتيبات لاحداث انتقال سريع الى عمليه
انتخابيه تنافسيه ما بين هذا ما بين القوى
السياسيه لتحولت هذه الطاقه الجدليه
والطاقه العراقيه ما بين القوى السياسيه
من طاقه حربيه صداميه صناعيه الى طاقه
تنافسيه انتخابيه تنتج
حكومه محترف بها وحكومه لها سنه جماهيري
وبالتالي يمكنك ان كان من الممكن ان يتم
العبور ولكن تمدد الفتره الانتقاليه
والازدحامها بالاجنده هو الذي ادى الى
تفجير هذا الصراع التحدث البرهان ايضا عن
فتره انتقاليه قصيره ما المقصود بقصيره ما
المدى الزمني المتصور لهكذا فتره انتقاليه
ولماذا لا يحدد
ربما لان الامر الى الان هو محصور في
العمليات العسكريه والعمليات العسكريه في
ظل هذه في ظل وجودها واحتدام الصراع من
الصعوبه تحديد كيف يمكن اجراء هذه
الانتخابات في زمن محدد لان الامر كما قال
البرهان مرتبط بانتهاء العمليات العسكريه
والعمليات العسكريه الى الان لم تنتهي
فبالتالي اعتقد ان الفتره الانتقاليه
القصيره هي التي تسمح بان تكون هنالك
ترتيبات اجرائيه سليمه لانتاج انتخابات
اللي خوض انتخابات نزيهه ذات مصداقيه تنتج
قياده متفق بها من قبل الجمهور شكرا لك
بلال الكاتب والمحلل السياسي السوداني كنت
معنا هنا
الى تطورات في كندا حيث قالت سلطات الارمن
في الاقليم انها بدات حل جيشها المعروفه
باسم جيش الدفاع في ارتساخه وسحب قواتها
من خطوط الاشتباك والمواقع القتاليه على
حدود الاقليم الى مواقعها الدائمه واضافت
في بيان انه بموجب اتفاق وقف القتال فانها
ستبدا في تنفيذ ماء اتفق عليه مع اذربيجان
ويتضمن ايضا تنظيم مشاورات سياسيه بشان
مستقبل الاقليم وشعبه
يخوض ارمن واقليم كرافاخ مفاوضات قاسيه مع
اذربيجان بعد استسلامهم
اعلنت سلطات الاقليم يوم السبت انها بدات
عمليه حل جيشها المعروف باسم جيش الدفاع
وسحب قواتها من خطوط الاشتباك والمواقع
القتاليه على حدود الاقليم وذلك بموجب
اتفاق وقف الاعمال العدائيه المبرم مع
اذربيجان ببساطه ورعايه روسيه
ونشرت وزاره الدفاع الاذربيجانيه صورا
قالت انها تبين مواقع عسكريه اخلاها
المسلحون الارمن في الاقليم واكدت قوه حفظ
السلام الروسيه ان المسلحين الارمن سلموا
عددا من المدرعات ومئات قطع الاسلحه
الخفيفه ومضادات للدبابات وكميات كبيره من
الذخيره وتامل السلطات الاقليم الارمينيه
بموجب الاتفاق في تنظيم مشاورات سياسيه
حول المستقبل ونقل جرح العمليات الذين
يعانون من اصابات خطيره الى ارمينيا عن
طريق الصليب الاحمر الدولي وقوات حفظ
السلام الروسيه واستيراد السلع الاساسيه
الماسه والادويه والوقود منها
وحسب الجهات الانسانيه فان الاف المدنيين
في مدينه ستبانك عاصمه الاقليم يعيشون
ظروفا انسانيه قاسيه وان المدينه تعيش في
ظلام دامس وينعدم فيها الغذاء والدواء
والوقود ولا يزال كثيرون يبحثون عن
اقاربهم المفقودين وذكر ان الرئيس الهام
علي اف امر بتشكيل فريق عمل للتعامل
الفوري مع القضايا الاجتماعيه والانسانيه
والاقتصاديه في الاقليم وان وزاره الطوارئ
الاذربيجانيه ارسلت فعلا قافله محمله
بمواد الاغاثه الى الاقليم كما عبرت قافله
مساعدات تابعه للصليب الاحمر الدولي ممر
لاتشين في ارمينيا باتجاه اقليم كاراباخ
وهي القافله الاولى منذ استعاده باكو
السيطره على الاقليم
قصه نهايه الصراع بين ارمينيا واذربيجان
المتعلق باقليم كرباخ والمستمر منذ نحو
ثلاثه عقود قد تبدو اذا وشيكه لكنها لا
تزال محفوفه بالصعاب ويتظاهر مناهضون
للحكومه في شوارع ريفان عاصمه ارمينيا
يوميا احتياجا على تعامل الحكومه
الارمينيه مع القضيه ويطالبون باستقاله
رئيس الوزراء
الذي يدعو الى الهدوء والمضي على طريق
السلام رغم كونه غير سهل
ينضم الينا من باكو مراسل جزيره عامر لافي
وايضا من يريفان مراسل الجزيره امين
دورغامي عامر ابدا معك ما المعلومات
المتوفره حول تسليم الاسلحه بحسب الجهات
الاذربيجانيه
نعم فداء يعني بالنسبه لعمليه تسليم
الاسلحه وزاره الدفاع الاذربيجانيه تحدثت
في بيان الله اليوم عن ان عمليه تسليم
الاسلحه مستمره لكنها لم تعطي كثيرا من
التفاصيل عن الى اين وصلت هذه العمليه وان
كانت يعني مصادرنا تتحدث من في وزاره
الدفاع اخبرونا بان العمليه تجري على ما
يرام وهي يعني تسير بشكل جيد لحد الان لكن
وزاره الدفاع تكتفي الان باصدار وببث
الكثير من المقاطع المصوره التي تظهر
سيطرتها على مواقع كثيره كانت قوات قوات
الارمينيه في كارباح قد انسحبت منها وتظهر
ايضا وتبث مقاطع لكميات كبيره من الاسلحه
التي خلفتها وراءها حتى ان وزاره الدفاع
الاذربيجانيه نشرت قائمه بالاف الاسلحه
والذخائر التي خلفتها وقالت ان هذه ليس كل
الاسلحه وانما ايضا الكثير كلما تقدم
الجيش في المناطق التي انسحبت منها هذه
القوات وهذا ربما ما دفع اليوم المساعد
رئيس الجمهوريه حكمه حجياف بالقول بان
التوصل الى فكره الاندماج وتحقيق فكره
اندماج لابد ان تمر عبر نقطتين اساسيتين
وهي تسليم الاسلحه وحل هذه الميليشيات كما
قال او الجماعات المسلحه غير الشرعيه هذا
لماذا قال هذا الكلام قال لانه بسبب هذه
الكميه من الاسلحه التي عثر عليها حيث قال
ان اذربيجان وتحديدا كارباخ اصبحت اكثر
المناطق ربما في العالم تسليحا قال بانها
قنبله موقوته اصبحت لهذه المنطقه مقارنه
بالمساحه وبعدد السكان هي كميه هائله من
الاسلحه يقول وبالتالي يجب ان يتم حل هذه
الميليشيات على حد وصفه ومن ثم تبدا عمليه
الاندماج المشكله هنا فداء ان هناك نوع من
انعدام الثقه بين الطرفين وهو الذي ربما
يصعب الامور نحن نتحدث عن 30 سنه من
الدماء من النزاع من الصراع الاذر بجنيون
يقولون بان ما جرى خلال هذه الفتره هو ان
ليس فقط ارمى كارباخ سيطروا على هذا
الاقليم في وسط اذربيجان وانما سيطروا على
سبعه اقاليم اخرى مساحه تقدر بعشرين
بالمئه من مساحه اذربيجان وارتكبت الكثير
من الجرائم ومن المجازر كما يقولونه
بالتالي هم ايضا الحاجه لعدم تكرار ما جرى
ننتقل الى امينه على الجانب الاخر امين
يتم تجديد على اهميه وجود ضمانات امنيه في
ظل مظاهرات شعبيه رافضه لهذا الاتفاق كيف
تبدو الصوره
صحيح فدا هناك مظاهرات ما زالت متواصله
اليوم خفت حده هذه الاحتجاجات الى انها
ستستمر غدا يوم الاحد بحسد دعوات من اسماء
في المعارضه الارمنيه الذين دعوا الى
الخروج والتظاهر من جديد في ساحه
الجمهوريه طبعا كل هذا ياتي في اطار ذلك
الضغط الشعبي على حكومه هنا في ارمينيا
الجو العام لم
يستسغ هذا الاتفاق في شكله وفي مضمونه وفي
طريقه حتى التي يتم الان تطبيقه تطبيق هذا
الاتفاق بها طبعا هناك مسائل كثيره ما
زالت عالقه بالرغم من ان البوادر الاولى
لتنفيذ الاتفاق بدات تظهر من خلال تسليم
الاسلحه دخول المساعدات الانسانيه تسليم
المواقع والخطوات المتعلقه بحل ما كان
يعرف بالجيش ارتساخ في اقليم كارباخ من
ارمن هذا الاقليم الى ان هناك مسالتين
اساسيتين الان عليهما الخلاف المساله
الاولى هي مساله الضمانات الامنيه بعدم
متابعه قضائيه
لاولئك المسلحين والمساله الثانيه طبعا
تتعلق بتقديم ضمان امن السكان ذلك الاقليم
وايضا مساله الثقه
الثقه التي ما زالت مفقوده بين الجانبين
هنا لربما ما يفسر هذا الحراك الدبلوماسي
الذي تقوده هيريفان تمثل اليوم من خلال
اتصال هاتفي اجراه رئيس الوزراء
مع وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
بلينكن تم التطرق بالتحديد لمساله كيفيه
تقديم الضمانات الامنيه اريفان الان تحاول
حشد مزيد من المواقف الدوليه من الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه من الاتحاد الاورو
تمثلت ايضا امس من خلال زياره مبعوثه
الاتحاد الى منطقه جنوب القوقاز وايضا من
خلال
المطالب ايضا الشعبيه التي تركز على هذه
المساله
بتقديم ضمانات امنيه وعدم السماح باتخاذ
خطوات ربما خارج هذا الاتفاق فيما يطلق
عليه هنا بالخطوات الانتقاميه من قبل
اذربيجان هناك مخاوف في الحقيقه عميقه في
هذا الشان ربما هذا ما يفسر تواصل هذه
المظاهرات والزياده ايضا الضغط على حكومه
شكرا لك والشكر موصول لعامر لافيا مراسل
الجزيره من باكو
قتل 18 شخصا واصيب 40 اخرون في حصيله
مرشحه للارتفاع بعد هجوم الانتحاريا
بشاحنه ملغمه في بلده بلد وين وسط الصومال
واكد مسؤول في الشرطه ان الهجوم استهدف
نقطه تفتيشا وان اغلب الضحايا مدنيون
الصومال الذي يستحصي عليه التخلص من
الهجمات الانتحاريه مقاومه افراد الشرطه
عند نقطه تفتيش في بلده بلداوين لم توقف
المشهد المروع الذي خلفه انفجار الشاحنه
الملغومه اغلب القتل من المدنيين الذين
كانوا في المكان والتوقيت الغلط تضرر عدد
من المباني بسبب شده الانفجار وتلقت قوه
الامن الصوماليه التي تحاول السيطره على
الوضع في البلاد ضربه مؤلمه اخرى مسرح
الهجومي بلده بلداوين التي تقع في اقليم
هيران بوسط الصومال اقليم شهد في الفتره
الاخيره معارك بين الجيش ومسلحي حركه
الشباب التي تقض مضاجع البلاد والعباد منذ
15 عاما جاء الهجوم الاخير بعد ايام من
اعتراف حكومه مقديشو بتعرض قوتها الامنيه
لانتكاسات كبيره عديده منذ اغسطس الماضي
في رساله طويله بعثها مستشار الامن القومي
الص حسين علي الشيخ الى الامم المتحده
بتاريخ التاسع عشر من الشهر الجاري طلب
تاجيل سحب ثلاثه الاف جندي من قوه حفظ
السلام التابعه للاتحاد الافريقي المعروفه
اختصارا باكمس مده التاجيل المطلوبه ثلاثه
اشهر للسماح للقوات المحليه باعاده تنظيم
صفوفها ضمنما جاء في الرساله اقرار علي
الشيخ ان الهجوم الذي شنه مسلح حركه
الشباب في السادس والعشرين اغسطس الماضي
على منطقه
دفع بالقوه الحكوميه الى الانسحاب من عده
بلدات كانت تحت سيطرتها تحدث عن تحول غير
متوقعه في الاحداث كشف نقاط ضعف في الخطوط
الاماميه للقوات الحكوميه كان من المقررين
ان تبدا المرحله الثانيه لسحب قوات ادمس
بحلول الثلاثين من سبتمبر الجاري لخفض عدد
افرادها الى اكثر من اربعه عشر الفا اي
مصير ينتظر الصومال بعد الانسحاب الكامل
لقوات اتمس المقرر نهايه العام المقبل
المده المتبقيه لرحيل اخر جندي اجنبي من
البلاد ليست كافيه لتشكيل الجيش وقوات
الشرطه قويه وقادره على القضاء نهائيا على
حركه الشباب التي تحكم قبضتها على مناطقها
في البلاد بعثه اتمست تتمتع بتفويض
لمحاربه الحركه التي تابى ان تختفي من
المشهد الصومالي المعقد منذ سنوات طويله
الحرب عليها مستمره وحربها على حكومه
مقديش لا تتوقف وغالبا ما يكون ضحاياها
مدنيين عزلا كانوا في بيوتهم او في فندق
او مروا من شارع حولهم تفجيرا الى اشلاء
متى يعرف هذا البلد السلام الذي فارقه منذ
عام 1991
[موسيقى]
افاد مراسل الجزيره بان الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي قصف نقطه رصد تابعه للمقاومه
الفلسطينيه شرقيه غزه بينما قال جيش
الاحتلال انه استهدف بمسيره موقعا عسكريا
تابعا لحركه حماس بالقرب من السياج
الحدودي في قطاع غزال ياتي ذلك عقب قمع
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي مظاهره قرب
الحدود شرقي مدينه غزه ما خلف اصابه عدد
من الشبان الفلسطينيين
اطلقت اللجنه الدوليه لكسر حصار غزه حمله
بعنوان افتحوا موانئ غزه بمبادره من
فلسطينيين خارج ونشاطات وذلك للتذكير
بالحصار الاسرائيلي المفروض على القطاع
واثاره على السكان وتجوب الحمله عددا من
الموانئ عبر العالم منها عربيه واوروبيه
وتمتد هذه الحمله لسته ايام تنتهي مع
نهايه الشهر الجاري
انطلقت هذه القوارب من شاطئ غزه
لكنها لن تبتعد كثيرا
فهذا المسير البحري ياتي ضمن حمله دوليه
لكسر حصار غزه بعنوان افتحوا موانئ غزه
حمله على شكل مظاهره بحريه في عدد من
الموانئ في الاردن وقطر وتركيا وبعض الدول
الاوروبيه ينظمها فلسطينيون الخارج لتجديد
الاحتجاج على استمرار الحصار الاسرائيلي
لقطاع غزه وتبعاته ارض غزه ومن ميناء قطاع
غزه المناشدات الفلسطينيه والدوليه لفك
الحصار وجهت بتكريس اسرائيلي له فقطاع غزه
لا توجد فيه الا موانئ متواضعه للصيادين
ومطارها دمره الاحتلال بالكامل منذ سنوات
والمحاولات المتكرره للقوافل البحريه لكسر
الحصار نجحت في مرات قليله بالوصول لشواطئ
غزه وتعمد الاحتلال بعدها منعها بالقوه
اليوم الرساله الاساسيه والاجابه مطلوبه
من المنظمات والمؤسسات الدوليه التي يفترض
بها ان تضع حدا لج الحصار التي غيبت قصرا
اكثر من 2 مليون و300 الف مواطن داخل قطاع
غزه وغيبت جيلا كاملا عن التواصل مع
العالم الخارجي حمله دوليه للتذكير بمخاطر
استمرار الحصار الاسرائيلي لقطاع غزه
وبضروره ايجاد موانئ للتخفيف من تداعياته
على حياه السكان هنا
فالحصار الذي تفرضه اسرائيل على قطاع غزه
منذ اكثر من 17 عاما زاد الاوضاع
الانسانيه سوءا واضر بجميع القطاعات
المعيشيه من كهرباء وصحه وادى الى تقييد
حركه المواطنين وفاق حجم الخسائر
الاقتصاديه خلال الحصار 17 مليار دولار
يعد الحصار على قطاع غزه جريمه حرب وجريمه
ضد الانسانيه تتطلب موقفا دوليا جدا من
اجل رفعه باعتبار يترك تداعيات كارثيه على
مجمل حاله حقوق الانسان
وما زالت اسرائيل تتمادى في سياساتها
الاحتلاليه رغم القرارات الدوليه
والمطالبات المتكرره بانهاء حصار قطاع غزه
هبه عكيلا الجزيره من مدينه غزه
قال الجيش اللبناني وان دوريه اسرائيليه
خرقت ما يعرف بخط الانسحاب في محيط مزارع
شبعه واطلقت قنابل دخانيه باتجاه عناصر من
الجيش كانت تؤازر جرافه تعمل على ازاله
ساتر ترابي في منطقه بسطره واضاف الجيش
اللبناني في بيان ان وحداته ردت باطلاق
قنابر مسيله لدموع باتجاه دوريه
الاسرائيليه ما اجبرها على الانسحاب من
جهتها نقلت مصادر اسرائيليه عن الجيش
الاسرائيلي قوله ان قواته اطلقت قنابل غاز
ودخان على جرافه لبنانيه تجاوزت الخط
الاخضر نحو اسرائيل من ناحيتها قالت قوات
اليونيفل انه وحداتها انتشرت في المنطقه
وتعمل على التواصل مع كافه الاطراف لتخفيف
حدث التوتر
قالت وكاله الانباء السعوديه ان وزير
الخارجات السعودي الامير فيصل بن فرحان
بحث مع نظيره الايراني حسين امير عبد
اللهيان اوجهها تكثيف اللقاءات التشاوريه
بما يخدم مصالح البلدين اضافه الى
المستجدات على الساحتين الاقليميه
والدوليه واضافت ان اللقاء الذي جرى على
هامش اعمال الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده
استعرض العلاقات المشتركه وسبل تعزيزها من
جانبها افادت خارجيه الايرانيه بان عبد
اللهيان اكد خلال اللقاء ان طهران تشدد
على مقترح تشكيل مجمع للحوار والتعاون بين
الدول المتشاطئه على مياه الخليج واستعداد
هذه الدول لاعداد وتوقيع وثيقه للتعاون
الشامل مع السعوديه وضروره تفعيل اللجنه
الاقتصاديه المشتركه
قال وزير الخارجات السعوديه الامير فيصل
بن فرحان ان بلاده ساعه لتحقيق الاستقرار
في المنطقه من خلال عقد جولات من
المباحثات مع ايران وضف وزير الخارجات
السعودي في كلمه امام الجمعيه العامه
للامم المتحده ان هذه المباحثات اسفرت عن
اتفاق بجين مشيرا الى ان الاتفاق قائم على
الاحترام المتبادل لسياده الدول
واستقلالها وعدم التدخل في شؤونها
الداخليه
من المملكه الاستقرار المنطقه فقط عقدت
جولات من المباحثات مع الجمهوريه
الاسلاميه الايرانيه استضافتها بغداد
واسقط ثم اسفرت باتفاق بكن الذي دشنا
استئناف التمثيل الدبلوماسي والتواصل
المباشره بين البلدين على اساس الاحترام
المتبادله لسياده الدول واستقلالها وامنها
وعدم التدخل في شؤونها الداخليه واحترام
الميثاق الامم المتحده منظمه التعاون
الاسلاميه
واكد وزير الخارجات السعوديه الامير فيصل
بن فرحان حرصه بلاده على امن واستقرار
اليمن ودعم جميع الجهود الراميه الى حل
الاسماء
تؤكد المملكه فرصه على امن واستقرار
للجمهوريه اليمنيه الشقيقه ودعم جميع
الجهود الراميه لحل الازمه في اليمن ورفع
المنعزات الانسانيه عن الشعب اليمني
الشقيق والدفع نحو الوصول الى الحلول
السياسيه لاعاده الامن والاستقرار الى
اليمن ودرء التهديد عن المملكه والمنطقه
كما تجدد التاكيد على مبادرتها لانهاء
الحرب في اليمن والتوصل للحل السياسي شامل
وتدعم الجهود الامويات الدوليه للتوصل الى
حل سياسي وفقا للمرجعيات الثلاث ومنها
قرار مجلس الامن 22/16
جدد وزير الخارجيه المصري سامح شكري موقف
بلاده الرافد لاي اجراءات احاديه في اداره
مياه نهر النيل اضاف شكري في كلمه امام
الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده ان اثيوبيا
تمادت في ملء وتشغيل سد النهضه بشكل احادي
في خرق صريح لقواعد القانون الدولي وافقه
تعبيره
تمادت اثيوبيا بالاستمرار في ملئه وتشغيله
بشكل احادي في خرق صريح صريح لقواعد
القانون الدولي واتفاق اعلان المبادئ 2015
والبيانه الرئاسي لمجلس الامن الصابر في
عام 2021
وعلى الرغم من استمرار الممارسات الاحاديه
للاشقاء في اثيوبيا تحرس مصر على استمرار
الانخراط بجديه في عمليات التفاوض الجاريه
والتي امتدت لما يزيد عن عقد كامل للوصول
الى اتفاق ملزم بشان قواعد الملا والتشغيل
بما يحفظ الحقوق والمصالح المشتركه
من جانبها قال وزير الخارجيه
ترحب باستئناف المحادثات الثلاثيه مع مصر
والسودان بشان سد النهضه واكد خلال كلمتها
امام الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده ان
اثيوبيا لا تزال ملتزمه بالتوصل الى نتيجه
تفاوضيه مربحه للجميع
يعد سد النهضه الاثيوبي الكبير احد
المشاريع التي تلبي التطلعات التنمويه
المشروعه للاثيوبيين والمنطقه ككل وترحب
اثيوبيا باستئناف المحادثات الثلاثيه مع
مصر والسودان ولا نزال ملتزمين بالتوصل
الى نتيجه تفوضيه مربحه للجميع ييسرها
الاتحاد الافريقي
واستمرون معكم في الحصاد وفي العناوين
في اليوم الثالث عشر لكارثه السيول بدء
عمليات اغاثه المنكوبين جوا غربي
استمرار عمليات انتشال الجثث في البحر
وجهود مكثفه لفتح الطرق المؤديه للمناطق
المنكوبه
وفي المغرب الحكومه تعلن فتح كل طرق
المتضرره وتقول انها ستطلق برامج تنميه
جديده في المناطق المنكوبه
القرم في مرمى الاستهداف الاوكراني لليوم
الثاني السلطات الروسيه تعلن تصديها لهجوم
صاروخيا على مرفا ستوبول كاف تعلن مقتل
شخصيات قياديه بالهجوم على الاسطول الروسي
يقول ان الغرب يخوض قتالا مباشرا ضد روسيا
في اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
على وقع معارك مستمره في الخرطوم رئيس
مجلس السياده السوداني يحذر في تصريحات
للجزيره من توسع الصراع الى خارج البلاد
يقول انه بحث في لقاء مع البرهان ما وصفه
بالنشاطات غير القانونيه للمجموعات
المسلحه المموله من روسيا
[موسيقى]
تستمر فرق البحث والانتشال في عملها
بمدينه درنا الليبيه للعثور على جثث
الضحايا سواء في المدينه او تلك التي
جرفتها السيوله التفاصيل في التقرير
التالي
لا يمكن تقديم رقم دقيق لعدد الضحايا او
المفقودين جراء عاصفه دانيال ومات لها من
سيول الجارفه المعلوم ان الفريق المسؤول
عن البحث عن ناجين في دارنا انها مهمه
بمرور عشره ايام وبالتالي تراجعت اي فرص
بالعثور على احياء
وبغياب اي ارقام مؤكده تحسن منظمه الصحه
العالميه حتى الان اكثر من 4000 وفاه في
درنه بينما لا يزال اكثر من ثمانيه الاف
شخص في عداد المفقودين والارقام مرشحه
للارتفاع التحدي حاليا يكمن في اخراج جثه
الضحايا ودون ذلك عقبات كثيره اهمها ضعف
المعدات التقنيه الخاصه بالكشف عن مواقع
الجثث برا وبحرا
في المدينه تبحث فرق الانقاذ عن الضحايا
في الابنيه المنهاره والمناطق التي غمرتها
المياه والطم وما جرفه السيل في طريقه
ولهذا الغرض يتم غالبا اللجوء الى اساسيات
الحفر والتنقيب اليدوي وتدخل اليات غير
ثقيله وكلاب مدربه على تحديد مواقع
الضحايا وبعد الاعلان عن انهاء عمل فرق
الانقاذ تتحول الى فرق بحث وانتشال حيث
يمكن ادخال معدات ثقيله والحاجه في درنا
تتمحور حول معدات اكثر تطورا والتي يمكن
ان تستخدم لرصد الاحياء وجثث الضحايا
كتقنيه ليدار التي ترتبط باقمار صناعيه
تربط بجهاز الملاحه جي بي اس وكاميرا
فوقيه ترسل اشارات للقمر الصناعي بما
تتلقاه من معلومات بعد بث نبضات ليزر
للبحث عن احياء او ضحايا
كما تحتاج فرق البحث الى تعزيز قدراتها
على البحث عن جثه الضحايا التي جرفتها
السيول الى البحر وهذا يعني الحاجه لفراق
غطس متخصصه باستخراج الضحايا وزوارق قادره
على تنفيذ عمليه بحث وانتشال والعوده الى
الشواطئ وفي حاله درنا العوده الى شواطئ
يتراكم فيها الحطام وتتبدى الصعوبات
اللوجستيه في التعامل مع الناجين ايضا حيث
نفذت السلطات عمليه اغاثه جويه لسكان
منطقه وادي الناقه غربيه درنه وتقدر
السلطات ان 80% من البنيه التحتيه وخمسين
في المئه من الطرق تضررت بفعل الكارثه
قلى محمد الجارح الناطق باسم لجنه الطوارئ
التابعه للحكومه المكلفه من مجلس النواب
ان اجماليه عدد الوفيات في المناطق
المتضرره من السيول التي ضربت مناطق شرق
ليبيا بلغ
3,845 واضاف الجارح في مؤتمر صحفيا في
بنغازي ان النائب العام شكل لجنتين
للابلاغ عن المفقودين في درنا والمناطق
المتضرره موجهه نداء الى اهالي المفقودين
لتسجيل محاضر الابلاغ عن ذويهم
قام النائب العام بتشكيل لجنه لجنه لعمليه
الحصر والتوثيق الخاصه بالتعريف عن
المفقودين وتم تشكيل فريقين رقم واحد او
المنطقه الاولى هي في منطقه شيحه الغربيه
في مقر الخدمات الضمانيه والثاني في منطقه
باب طبرق في مقر الخدمات الصحيه
ويعني نوجه نداء لكل من لديه
المدينه درنه وايضا المناطق المتضرره في
انهم هم يذهبوا ويقوموا بعمليه الابلاغ عن
المفقودين في النقطتين هذه
معنى من دارنا سالم ان عاصمه الهلال
الاحمر بدرنه سيد سالم بعد 13 يوما من
فيضانات دارنه وهذه السيوله الجارفه كيف
تبدو عمليات انتشال الجثث وايضا المساعدات
السلام عليكم جميعا مساء الخير
في الحقيقه اعمال الانتشار لساده مستمره
الدوري الهلال الاحمر توقف عن عمليه
الانتشار الان يعمل على تسجيل المفقودين
وعلى
الاغاثه وعلى
التوزيع الاغاثه بالمدينه
التسجيل المفقودين
بالنسبه لانتشال جثث حاليا تقوم بالفرق
الاجنبيه على الارض وهي الروسي الفريق
الايطالي ومن مصر ايضا نحن الان نعمل على
منظومه تقييم نقيم في
نقيم الارقام الاساتذه بالمفقودين يوميا
تاتي حوالي 35
بلغ عن المفقودين اي معايير تقومون بذلك
ما هي الاليه
طبعا الاليه نحن بالنسبه لاليه المفرودين
لدينا منظومه حاليا بدانا بالتسجيل بها
الان حوالي 1500 مفقود تم تسجيلهم في
المنظومه طبعا المنظومه هذه عن طريق ارقام
هاتفيه عن طريق الواتساب وعن طريق
المكالمات الهاتفيه تم توزيعها وعن طريق
رقم الطوارئ الخاص بالهلال الاحمر حيث يتم
تسجيل بيانات المفقود بالكامل
والمنطقه التي كانت موجود بها والاسم
الشخص الذي يقدم البلاغ ايضا مركز الايواء
لازالت مفتوحه ولا زال يوجد بها عائلات لا
يظل الهلال الاحمر يعمل على المراكز طبعا
حوالي اربعه مراكز في المنطقه في المنطقه
الغربيه يعمل الهلال الاحمر على مركزين
لكن في نفس الوقت يقوم بالاشراف على
المراكز الاخرى من ناحيه المعلومات
والبيانات لان الفريق التقييم يقوم بجوله
كامله
المخصصه لهذه العمليه هل من حد اقصى
والله شوف الحد الاقصى هو انتهاء انتهاء
اي او اخر مكالمه مع المقادير لانها حضرتك
تفهمين واعيه
الشارثه لازال هناك اشخاص مفقودين لا زال
هناك اشخاص لا يريدون ان يبلغوا عن عن
عائلاتهم المطلوبه املين من الله عز وجل
ان يرجعون فبعض منهم لا يزال ان تتحدثين
اليوم حوالي 40 في حاله بلاغ مع المفقودين
الجاليه المصريه لدينا مفقودين كثيرين بها
وجيه التي وهم يعتبرون من العماله الوافده
في المدينه
لا يزال اعدادهم كبيره وايضا مراكز اللواء
تضم العماله المصريه
طبعا مركز اللواء نعمل على سجل الاجراءات
الاحترازيه بها لكثره لكثره العائلات
الموجوده بها الاعداد يعني بعض العائلات
غادرت الى مدينه بنغ ازي الى الغرب عن
طريق حافلات
المسلحه والبعض منها رفض مغادره المدينه
نعم يعني في الايام الماضيه استمعنا الى
شكاوي كثيره تتعلق في ضعف المعدات فيما
يتعلق بانتشال الجثث الفرق الاجنبيه هل
تجاوزت هذه المشكله
للاسف الشديد لا زالت هناك بعض العراقيل
كما تعلمين منذ ثلاث ايام او اربع ايام
عمليه الانتشار التجري على فيها في قطاع
البحر يعني معظم الجثث البحر يعني شد
حدثين في ثلاثه ايام تم انتشار حوالي 500
جثه يعني من البحر تم دفنها في منطقه
مكتوبه اجمال الجثث بالامس كان لدي اتصال
مع احد الاشخاص الموجودين بالمقبره وهو من
احد سكان مدينه مرسوبه قال لي بان العدد
الذي مسكون الان في مقبره حوالي 1550 شخص
مقابل للزياده نعم
شكرا لك سيد سالم النعاس مسؤول الاعلام في
الهلال الاحمر كنت معنا من درنه
[موسيقى]
الى تداعيات زلزال الحوز في المغرب حيث
اعلنت وزاره التجهيز فتحه الطرق الرئيسيه
المتضرره بشكل كامل بينما وصلت نسبه فتح
الطرق الفرعيه الى اكثر من 90% وتتواصل
عمليه احصاء المنازل المتضرره في المناطق
المنكوبه جراء الزلزال الذي ضرب منطقه
الحوز الشهر الجاري بالتزامن مع عمليات
الاخاده الاغاثه التي ينفذها الجيش
المغربي في المنطقه وتواصل اللجان التقنيه
المغربيه في الاقاليم المنكوبه احصاء الاف
المباني المتضرره وقد اكد رئيس الحكومه
المغربيه عزيز اخنوش ان الحكومه ستطلق
برامج تنميه جديده في المناطق المنكوبه
قالت وزاره الاقتصاد والماليه المغربيه
انه سيتم استحداثه وكاله ستشرف على برنامج
اعاده بناء المناطق المتضرره من زلزال
الحوز الذي خصص له مبلغ اثني عشر مليار
دولار على مدى خمس سنوات واضافت وزاره
الاقتصاد والماليه المغربيه ان عمل
الوكاله سيكون مؤقتا ومرتبطا بمده برنامج
اعاده وبناء المناطق المتضرره وستقوم
بتتبع صرف المساعدات وانجاز مشاريع اعاده
البناء والتاهيل بالاضافه الى التنسيق بين
مختلف القطاعات وتنفيذ مشاريع التنميه
في الاثناء قال مسؤولون في بلديه مراكش
للجزيره ان نسبه الانتهاء من عمليه ايواء
المنكوبين المتضررين من الزلزال في مراكش
بلغت نحو 95% بينما تجاوزت نسبه انجاز
عمليه الاحصاء للمنازل المتضرره 50% في
المدينه القديمه وبحسب مسؤولي البلديه فان
قرارات الهدم جاهزه وستخدم كل المنازل
التي تضررت كليا واعاده بناء مساكن جديده
من ناحيه اخرى تحولت قاعات رياضيه في
مدينه مراكش الى ماوى لمئات الاسر التي
تعرضت منازلها لادراجها
غير زلزال الحوز انماط عيش سكان قرى في
اقاصي جبال الاطلس بالمغرب حيث دمر عددا
منها مضطر الاهالي الى المغادره نحو مناطق
اخرى امنه بعيده عن موطنهم الاصلي ويمثل
هذا الانتقال تحديا لكبار السن الذين لا
يقدرون على التنقل في المسالك الوعره
علاوه على صعوبه ايجاد مساحات جغرافيه
لنصب الخيام خصوصا في المناطق الجبليه
الوعره
بصعوبه تشق العربه طريقها في الممر الجبلي
فالطريق نحو بلده امنزل بالحوز بات اكثر
خطوره بعد الزلزال بعد ان قطعنا خمسه
كيلومترات من بلده سيتي فاطمه وجدنا من
نزح من اهالي امنزل وهو تجمع سكاني صغير
في الريف معروف بالدوار وقد نصب الخيام في
احد المنعرجات بعد ان دمر الزلزال بيوتهم
الطينيه البسيطه
ومن تلك الاقاصيل بعيده قدم من استطاع
منهم سيرا على الاقدام وبقي نفر من كبار
السن عالقين في الاعالي لا حول لهم ولا
قوه
هذا المسن رفاق دربه العالقين بعيدا لكن
ما باليد حيله اما شباب القريه فهم الان
في اجتماع طارئ يمتلكون العزيمه لكنهم
يفتقدون الامكانات فتحوا باب التطوع املا
في فتح الطريق المدمر الذي لا تسلكه الا
البغال
حياه اخرى مغايره في مستقرهم الجديد خيام
قدمتها السلطات وطعام جاد به المحسنين يسد
رمق الجياع عند مشاكل ديال
المراه اللي باتت ولد صراحه
للسبيطار
الى هنا وصل فريق طبي متطوع من المغاربه
المقيمين في فرنسا نساء البلده يشتكين
الفاقه والمرض ويحتجن للعلاج
الطبيب زهير لهنا بات هو الاخر يفكر في
حلول لانقاذ كبار السن العالقين في البلده
لا بد ان نخرجها من الدوار في اسرع وقت ان
شاء الله منهم سبعه ناس من يعني كبار السن
نتمنى اما هما
النعش ونتمنى اذا كانت مروحيه في المستقبل
من يوصل الصوت ديالنا يمشي ويجيبوا هذا
الناس لا يستطيعون المشي لكل واحد من
اهالي بلده امنزل قصه مع زلزال الحوز الذي
خلف ندوبا غائرا وجراحا لا تندمل فما قبل
الزلزال ليس كما بعده
لا تلوح في الافق نهايه قريبه لمعاناته
السكان بلده امنزل كغيرهم من سكان المناطق
المتضرره لكن الشتاء القارص الذي يمتد
لاشهر سيكون اشد وطئه من الزلزال في
انتظار اعاده بناء ما دمر المختار
العبداوي الجزيره اقليم الحوز وسط المغرب
[موسيقى]
الى حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا حيث تعرضت شبه
جزيره القرم لهجوم صاروخي وثاني من نوعه
خلال 24 ساعه وقد اعلن الحاكم الروسي
لمدينه سيفاستوبول ان الدفاعات الجويه
تتصدت لهجوم صاروخيا سقط حطامه في مرفع
المدينه بينما اعلن الجيش الاوكراني ان
هجومه على مقر الاصول البحري الروسي في
القرم امس استهدف اجتماعا لقاده في
البحريه الروسيه مع ادى الى مقتل عدد منهم
لم يجب الدخان عن سماء سيفاستوبول حتى عاد
من جديد للمره الثانيه خلال 24 ساعه تتعرض
المدينه جنوبي القرم لهجوم اوكراني يقول
حاكم المدينه الروسيه ان الدفاعات الجويه
تصدت لهجوم صاروخي سقط حطامه في مرفا
المدينه كالامس تعلق حركه نقل الركاب في
خليج سيفاستبول ففي الامس تقول القوات
الاوكرانيه انها استهدفت اجتماعا لقياده
البحريه الروسيه ما ادى الى مقتل تسعه من
القاده العسكريين الروس في المدينه كانت
موسكو قد اكدت حينها ان جنديا واحدا فقط
قتل في الهجوم اذ استهدفت كييف مقر اسطول
البحر الاسود الروسي وذلك اسطول يتبع
للبحريه الروسيه ووظيفته تامين الحدود
الجنوبيه لروسيا كما يملك قطعا عسكريه
بحريه متنوعه تعزز الوجود العسكريه
الروسيه في بحري ازوف والاسود وهما بحراني
تنطلق منهما العمليات العسكريه الروسيه في
المناطق الجنوبيه من اوكرانيا سواء
بالصواريخ التي تطلق من القطع البحريه
هناك او بالامداد اللوجستي للقوات البريه
في شبه جزيره القرم منطلق الهجمات الروسيه
في الجبهه الجنوبيه هكذا تتحول القرم
وسباسبول تحديدا الى مركز استراتيجي
لروسيا سياسيا وعسكريا وهدف استراتيجيا
لاوكرانيا عسكريا باضعاف خط الامداد
الرئيسي في المنطقه الجنوبيه للروس
وسياسيا بالتاكيد على احقيه كييف بضرب
اراضيها المحتله كما تقول منذ عام 2014
غير بعيد عن القرم والسباستيوبول
الاستراتيجيه يتواصل القتال على خطوط
التماس الجنوبيه هناك تسعى القوات
الاوكرانيه بكل قوتها الى تحقيق اختراق
حقيقي نحو القرم من الجهه الشماليه تستهدف
مدينه ميلوتوبول الواقعه على خط القطار
الرئيسي من زبولوجي انا حول القرم تقول
تلك القوات انها الحقت خسائر فادحه في
الجيش الروسي هناك غير بعيد عن زبروجيا
تقول القوات الروسيه انها قتلت اربعه الاف
جندي اوكراني على خطوط الجبهه هناك خلال
الاسبوع الماضي بالاضافه الى تدمير
مخزونات الصواريخ المجنحه وقذائف
اليورانيوم المنظم التي استلمتها كييف من
الغرب هكذا يؤكد كل طرف على روايته في ضرب
الاخر وتحقيق التقدم لكن الاعين الان
تتركز على القرم لتكون مسرح العمليات
الاوكرانيه المكثفه قبل الشتاء
انضموا الينا من الزيورخ العقيده الكساندر
رئيس تحرير المجله العسكريه السويسريه
عقيد الكسندر ما فعاليه الهجمات التي
تنفذها اوكرانيا في شبه جزيره القرم
هذا الهجوم يبين
قوه ومحدوديه اوكرانيا من الناحيه التقنيه
كان هذا الهجوم منسقا بشكل جيد ومنفذا
بشكل جيد وبين ان
الاوكرانيين لديهم قدرات دقيقه عسكريه
ولكن
لا معنى كثيرا من وراءها لانها كان ينبغي
ان تكون هذا الهجمات قد تمت في بدايه
الهجوم اعتقد انها تاتي متاخره بعض الشيء
الان سيد اليكسان ولكن هنالك من يرى بان
هذه الهجمات انما تشتت الدفاعات الجويه
الروسيه خارج نطاق التماس تقضي على خطوط
الامداد الا ترى بانها يمكن ان تحقق هذه
الاهداف
طبعا
الصوت يتقطع من المصدر
الروس في القطع الجنوبي استخدموا
كثيرا من او استنفذوا كثيرا من قدراتهم
وفقدوا القدره على الترسيق ربما هذا قد
يفيد الاوكرانيين لكن لن يكون له تاثير
على الدفاعات الجويه ولا ستكون له تاثيرات
مباشره على القوات الاحتياطيه
وكذلك في منطقه زبروتشيا طيب على خطوط
اتماس الجنوبيه ايضا يشتد القتال ما قدره
اوكرانيا على تحقيق اختراق حقيقي في مده
زمنيه قريبه
لا حققوا عفوا
اكبر اختراق لهم حتى الان في نحو عام وقد
قاموا بذلك
جنوبروسيا فقط استطاعوا ان يفتحوا ثغرق
ثغره بحوالي ثلاثين كيلو مترا وهذه قد
تكون فرصه لكم لكن اذا كان الروس قد
استخدموا كل قدراتهم الاحتياطيه ولم يعد
لديهم ما يوقفوا به التقدم الاوكراني واذا
كانت قدراتهم التنظيميه قد تلاشت او
تزعزعت بفعل هجمات هذا اليوم وغيرها وهل
هذا وارد سيد عليك سانتا
هناك احتمالات بان يحدث هذا الشيء للاسف
تقديراتي انا بان الاوكرانيين لديهم قوات
قليله جدا من حيث العدد حتى يستطيعوا
استغلال هذا النجاح التكتيكي جنوب
زبروتشيا هم يحاولون خلق وضع هو حقيقه غير
مريح جدا
للجيش الروسي لكنني لست متاكدا من
الاوكرانيين
سيمتلكون القدره
لخرق الدفاعات ويتقدم بمئات الكيلومترات
لتحقيق النصر الحاسم شكرا لك عقيد الكسن
رئيس تحرير المجله العسكريه السويسريه كنت
معنا من الزيورخ
اتهما وزير الخارجات الروسي
الدول الغربيه بخوض قتال مباشر ضد روسيا
في اوكرانيا وفي كلمه امام الجمعيه العامه
للامم المتحده انتقد لافروف التعامل
الغربيه مع مسالتي تمدد الناتو شرقا
والضمانات الامنيه التي طالبت بها بلاده
القيادات الغربيه لم تحترم وعودها بشان
عدم توسيع حلف شمال الاطلسي شرقا باتجاه
حدود روسيا وفي عام 2021 رفضت مقترحاتنا
بشان ضمانات امنيه متبادله دون تغيير وضع
اوكرانيا كدوله غير منحازه واستمر الغرب
في تسليح نظام كييف المعادي لروسيا
وطلب وزير الخارجات الروسي باعاده النظر
في اسس انشاء الامم المتحده والعمل على
توسيع مجلس الامن ليخرج من هيمنه الغرب
اوافقه قوله
لدى
ان الحاجه متزايده لتوسيع مجلس الامن
وتعزيز تمثيله لاخراجه من هيمنه الغرب يجب
اعاده النظر في القواعد التي تاسست عليها
الامم المتحده عقب الحرب العالميه الثانيه
لقد حان الوقت لاعتماد اليه منصفه لتشكيل
امانه المنظمه الدوليه واذا لم ترد واشنطن
وحلفائها التفاوض معنا بشان نظام عالمي
اكثر عداله فسنخوض ذلك بانفسنا
[موسيقى]
في تطورات الوضع في السودان تتواصل
المعارك بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع في مناطق مختلفه من العاصمه
الخرطومه فقد افادت مصادر محليه للجزيره
ان الجانبين يتبادلان القصف المدفعي
العنيف بمنطقه جبل اولياء جنوبيه العاصمه
وقالت مصادر للجزيره ان الجانبين تبادل
القصف المدفعي في محيط القياده العامه
للجيش في الوقت نفسه قال مكتب الامم
المتحده للشؤون الانسانيه ان خمسه ملايين
و300 الف انسان غادروا منازلهم في السودان
بسبب القتال المتواصل منذ اكثر من خمسه
اشهر
وفي مقابله مع قناه الجزيره الانجليزيه
اتهم رئيس مجلس السياده بالسودان عبد
الفتاح البرهان قائد قوات الدعم السريع
محمد حمدان حماتي لانه ينكث العهود وقال
البرهان ان الجيش السوداني يلتزم
باخلاقيات القتال لا سيما في المناطق
الحضريه
غير صادق هو من يهاجم الان
للنيابه هو من يهاجم الجنينه ومن يهاجم
المدن في كل مكان هو يهاجم القوات المسلحه
في مقراته لذلك في جده عندما توصلنا الى
تفاهمات لم يلتزم بها القوات المسلحه
لديها مسؤوليه
دستوريه تجاه حمايه الامن الدوله هي حمايه
الدوله من الانهيار حمايه الدوله من
التصدع ولذلك تستخدم القوه ضد من يحاول ان
يقوض الامن في الدوله ايضا القوات المسلحه
تلتزم بالقانون الدولي تلتزم بالمعايير
الاخلاقيه في العمليات العسكريه خاصه في
مناطق الحضره وفي المناطق المدنيه
كما قال البرهان للجزيره الانجليزيه انه
سيتم البدء في التحضير لعمليه سياسيه
شامله في السودان تمهيدا لاجراء انتخابات
بمجرد توقف القتال
نحن نعتقد اننا بمجرد توقف القتال او
الوصول الى حلول العمليات العسكريه يبدا
التحضير لعمليه سياسيه شامله
تعيد الاوضاع الاقتصاديه ترتب الاوضاع
الداخليه ثم تعد لانتخابات في نهايه فتره
انتقاليه قصيره نحن نقول ان الشعب
السوداني خرج في ثوره عظيمه في 2019
لديه احلام يريد ان يعيش في حريه وسلام
وعداله القوات المسلحه السودانيه لن تقف
حائلا دون تحقيق طموحات وتطلعاته
واضاف البرهان للجزيره الانجليزيه انما
وصفه بالمجموعات المتمرده اتت من دول
كثيره في الاقليم وحذر من ان الصراع
سينتقل الى تلك الدول اذا انتهى في
السودان او توسع خارجه
طبعا هذه المجموعات المتمرده اتت من دول
كثيره في الاقليم
لذلك هذا الصراع سينتقل الى تلك الدول
حتما اذا انتهى في السودان او اذا توسع
خارج السودان هنالك مقاتلين من معظم دول
الجوار
[موسيقى]
وقد بحث الرئيس الاوكراني فلاديمير
زيلنسكي مع رئيس مجلس السياده السودانيه
عبد الفتاح البرهان ما وصفه بالانشطه غير
القانونيه مجموعات المسلحه المموله من
روسيا واعرب خلال اللقائه البرهان في مطار
شانن في ايرلندا عقب مشاركته في اجتماعات
الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده في نيويورك
عن تقديره لموقف السودان الداعم لسياده
بلاده ووحده اراضيها كما ناقش طرفان الممر
البحريه لتصدير الحبوب الاوكرانيه التي
دعا سيلينسك البرهان الى طعمه
ينضم الينا من موسكو اندريه
الروسي كما ينضم الينا من لندن خالد لعيسر
الكاتب والباحث السياسي السوداني سيد خالد
ابدا معك وصف اللقاء بين زيلينسكي
والبرهان بالصدفه الى اي مدى يبدو منطقيا
هذا الوصف
تحيه لك والضيفك الكريم وللمشاهديكم
الكرام ايضا بالتاكيد هو محضي صدفه ان
كانت عمليه مرتبه كان يمكن ان تتم داخل
الولايات المتحده في نيويورك يعني جميعهم
كانوا في اجتماعات الجميعة العامه للامم
المتحده ولكن الذي تم هو لقاء عابر في
ايرلندا في كونكشن طبيعي ومن هذا ليس هناك
خصوصيه لهذا اللقاء تلغي بظلاله على مسيره
علاقات السودان مع الدول في المحيط او في
العالم اجمع لا سيما العلاقه مع دوله
روسيا تزمنا هذا اللقاء مع كلام ايضا عن
دعم القوات الاوكرانيه للجيش السوداني
وحديث الرئيس
ايزيلنسكي عن دعم روسيا لقوات او قوات
روسيه قوات مموله من قبل روسيا تعمل داخل
السودان وتعمل وتدعم قوات الدعم السريع
يعني كل هذه صدف
وبالتاكيد لا بد من النظر الى علاقات
السودان العسكريه ليست هي حديثه او ولده
صدفه بالتاكيد السودان الذي علاقات عسكريه
مع معظم دول العالم روسيا واوكرانيا معظم
السلاح الذي يستخدم في السودان هو من
هاتين الدولتين
وبالتاكيد هناك علاقات للسودان في محيط
العربي والافريقي برتوكولات التعاون عسكري
لا يوجد حرج في ان تكون هناك استمراريه
لعلاقه عسكريه بين السودان وروسيا من جهه
وبين السودان واوكرانيا ومن جهه لجلب
التكنولوجيا الحديثه المستخدمه في عدد من
الاليات والطائرات وما الى ذلك ولكن
بالتاكيد هي لم تكن صدفه ان يكون للسودان
علاقات استراتيجيه من الزاويه العسكريه
استمعنا كثيرا لانتغادات للسودان لتورط
بعض الجهات او وجوده داخل الجغرافيا
السودانيه وليس دل على ذلك الاتهام قوات
التمرد والمليشيا الارهابيه لوجود عسكري
في مطار مروي في الكذبه الاولى التي
اطلقتها يعني في العيون ولكن هي لم تعلم
ان هناك اتفاقات بين السودان ومصر وليس دل
على ذلك الا يعني المناورات التي جرت
مؤخرا تحت عنوان نسور النيل واحد اتنين
وبالتالي هذا ليس حديث اما فيما يلي
التورط الروسي او وجود روسي في السودان من
زاويه اخرى انا في تقديري ان هذا الامر
انتهى بقياب فاجنر بموجب المعطيات الجديده
محمد حمدان
لو سمحت لي سيد يعني الى اي مدى اتسع نطاق
المواجهه بين السودان عفوا بين روسيا
واوكرانيا ليشمل ساحات جديده كالسودان
مثلا
اوكرانيا تحاول ان تستغل كل الاوضاع حيث
كانت او يوجد هناك تواجد او النفوس الروسي
لضرب هذه المواقف الروسيه بما في ذلك
السودان فلذلك لا يوجد هناك شيء جديد طبعا
خاصه بعد التقارير تقول حتى توجد هناك او
يوجد هناك مدربين الاوكرانيين في صفوف
الجيش السوداني
ويشاركون ويدعمون في الجيش السوداني في
مواجهه ضد قوات الدعم السريع والى ما
هنالك
على ما يبدو زيلينسكي وسلطات الاوكرانيه
تحاول ان تستغل الاوضاع
انا اعتقد ان مساله روسيا حاليا تحاول ان
تراتب الامور مع فاجنر يعني فيها داخل
تحاول ان تعيد النظر على دور رواجنر
المختار على السحر الروسيه على سحر
الاوكرانيه في خارج حتى في الافريقيه
فلذلك انا لا اعتقد يوجد هناك دور قوي
في السودان لحد الان نفس الوقت هذا لا
يعني طبعا نحن نعلم او كان هناك على الاقل
الالتحامات بان كانت هناك تعاون بين قوات
فاجنر ودعم الصريح في السودان فلذلك يعني
هذا شيء الوحيد الذي يدفع
لتوجيه الاتهام ضد روسيا
لتضامن مع الجيش السوداني
اعود اليك سيد خالد سيد خالد ذكرتم بان
دور فاجنر انتهى بموت قائدها ولكن ما هي
المؤشرات والمعلومات المتوفره التي تدعم
هذه الحجه
وبالتاكيد المعطيات السياسيه في السودان
تغيرت كانت هناك ارتباطات وثيقه جدا بين
قوات الدعم السريع مليليه الدعم السريع
المتمرده وبعض العناصر من روسيا يعني لا
استطيع ان اؤكد انهم
يتبعونر او يتبعون لمواطنين من روسيا ولكن
انا شاهدت عيني في مراكز في الخرطوم وجود
لبعض الخبراء الروس في المجالات التقنيه
الاعلاميه
وتحديث
يعني مقتنيات الاعلام باشكال مختلفه
وهؤلاء يعني العلاقه بينه وبين قوات الدعم
السريع وليس الجيش ولكن لا حرج من ان يكون
للسودان علاقات من زاويه المؤسسه العسكريه
كان للسودان تبادل عسكري وتبادل خبرات مع
الصين ومع روسيا مع الولايات المتحده اما
تورط قوات الدعم السريع في عمليات عسكريه
افصعد عنها
مسيره الاخبار التي تواترت من افريقيا
الوسطى في مراحل سابقه
بمقتل عدد من قوات السريع في تورط عمليات
عسكريه في في افريقيا الوسطى وحين وقتها
لم يكن هناك قرار رسمي سوداني
لارسال والدعم السريعي لافريقي الوسطى من
الاحوال هذه كانت علاقات بين قائد الدعم
السريع المتمرد الذي كان يتحرك في الدوله
بحريه كامله ولديه سلطه القرار والقوه
العسكريه التي يعني لا تجيب اي التبعات
قانونيه او مسائله من قبل الدوله هذا
الامر انتهى في تقديره الدعم السريع الان
تلفظ انفاسها صحيح انها موجوده في الخرطوم
ولكن من ناحيه القدرات العسكريه هي ليس
لديها قدره عسكريه كافيه قياسا بما كان
عليه الحال في 15 ابريل الماضي سيد اندريه
يعني مع حدوده في السودان
نحن بحاجه الى تسويه الامور في السودان
المطاف كما تعلمين ربما روسيا تهتم يعني
انشاء القائد العسكريه البحريه في البحر
الاحمر وكانت هناك بعض الاتفاقيات مع
السودان سابقا في حول انشاء المركز البحري
اللوجستي في بورسودان فلذلك الاحزان الامر
يحتاج الى الهدوء في الدوله فلذلك على ما
يبدو روسيا تعمل مع كلا طرفين لاجل لتصفيه
الامور في السودان في نفس الوقت
ما تحتاجه روسيا هو عدم تدخل دول مثل
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه طبعا
روسيا ترحب بكل الادوار التي يمكن ان تؤدي
الى السلام في السودان ولكن ليس على حساب
روسيا
تجلى روسيا مصالح في السودان مصالح
العسكريه مصالح الاقتصاديه بعض المصالح
ذكرتها في قبل قليل
روسيا متمسكه بحمايه تلك المصالح فلذلك
طبعا
عندما تتعامل وتتعاون مع كلا طرفين فطبعا
تاخذ في عين الاعتبار هذه المصالح شكرا لك
الكاتبه المحلل السياسي والشكر موصول
للسيد خالد الاعيسر الكاتب والباحثه
السياسي من لندن
[موسيقى]
الى تطورات في كندا حيث قالت سلطات الارمن
في الاقليم انها بدات حل جيشها المعروف
باسم جيش الدفاع في ارسخ وسحب قواتها من
خطوط الاشتباك والمواقع القتاليه على حدود
الاقليم الى مواقعها الدائمه واضافت في
بيان انه وبموجب اتفاق وقف القتال فانها
ستبدا في تنفيذ ماء اتفق عليه مع اذربيجان
ويتضمن ايضا تنظيم مشاورات سياسيه بشان
مستقبل الاقليم او شعبه
يخوض ارمن واقليم كراباخ مفاوضات قاسيه مع
اذربيجان بعد استسلامهم
اعلنت سلطات الاقليم يوم السبت انها بدات
عمليه حل جيشها المعروف باسم جيش الدفاع
وسحب قواتها من خطوط الاشتباك والمواقع
القتاليه على حدود الاقليم وذلك بموجب
اتفاق وقف الاعمال العدائيه المبرم مع
اذربيجان ببساطه ورعايه روسيه
ونشرت وزاره الدفاع الاذربيجانيه صورا
قالت انها تبين مواقع عسكريه اخلاها
المسلحون الارمن في الاقليم واكدت قوه حفظ
السلام الروسيه ان المسلحين الارمن سلموا
عددا من المدرعات ومئات قطاع الاسلحه
الخفيفه ومضادات للدبابات وكميات كبيره من
الذخيره وتعمل السلطات الاقليم الارمينيه
بموجب الاتفاق في تنظيم مشاورات سياسيه
حول المستقبل ونقل جرح العمليات الذين
يعانون من اصابات خطيره الى ارمينيا عن
طريق الصليب الاحمر الدولي وقوات حفظ
السلام الروسيه واستيراد السلع الاساسيه
الماسه والادويه والوقود منها
وحسب الجهات الانسانيه فان الاف المدنيين
في مدينه ستبانك عاصمه الاقليم يعيشون
ظروفا انسانيه قاسيه وان المدينه تعيش في
ظلام دامس وينعدم فيها الغذاء والدواء
والوقود ولا يزال كثيرون يبحثون عن
اقاربيهم المفقودين وذكر ان الرئيس الهام
علي اف امر بتشكيل فريق عمل للتعامل
الفوري مع القضايا الاجتماعيه والانسانيه
والاقتصاديه في الاقليم وان وزاره الطوارئ
الاذربيجانيه ارسلت فعلا قافله محمله
بمواد الاغاثه الى الاقليم كما عبرت قافله
مساعدات تابعه للصليب الاحمر الدولي ممر
لاتشين في ارمينيا باتجاه اقليم كاراباخ
وهي القافله الاولى منذ استعاده باكو
السيطره على الاقليم
قصه نهايه الصراع بين ارمينيا واذربيجان
المتعلق باقليم كرباخ والمستمر منذ نحو
ثلاثه عقود قد تبدو اذا وشيكه لكنها لا
تزال محفوفه بالصعاب ويتظاهر مناهضون
للحكومه في شوارع ريفان عاصمه ارمينيا
يوميا احتياجا على تعامل الحكومه
الارمينيه مع القضيه ويطالبون باستقاله
رئيس الوزراء نيكول باشنيان الذي يدعو الى
الهدوء والمضي على طريق السلام رغم كونه
غير سهل
[موسيقى]
قتل 18 شخصا واصيب اربعون اخرون في حصيله
مرشحه للارتفاع بعد هجوم انت حاليا بشاحنه
مضغمه في بلده بلد وين وسط الصومال واكد
مسؤولا في الشرطه ان الهجوم استهدف نقطه
تفتيش وان اغلب الضحايا مدنيون
الصومال الذي يستحصي عليه التخلص من
الهجمات الانتحاريه مقاومه افراد الشرطه
عند نقطه تفتيش في بلده بلداوين لم توقف
المشهد المروع الذي خلفه انفجار الشاحنه
الملغومه اغلب القتل من المدنيين الذين
كانوا في المكان والتوقيت الغلط تضرر عدد
من المباني بسبب شده الانفجار وتلقت قوات
الامن الصوماليه التي تحاول السيطره على
الوضع في البلاد ضربه مؤلمه اخرى مسرح
الهجومي بلده بلداوين التي تقع في اقليم
هيران بوسط الصومال اقليم شهد في الفتره
الاخيره معارك بين الجيش ومسلحي حركه
الشباب التي تقض مضاجع البلاد والعباد منذ
15 عاما جاء الهجوم الاخير بعد ايام من
اعتراف حكومه مقديشو بتعرض قوتها الامنيه
لانتكاسات كبيره عديده منذ اغسطس الماضي
في رساله طويله بعثها مستشار الامن القومي
الصومالي حسين علي الشيخ الى الامم
المتحده بتاريخ التاسع عشر من الشهر
الجاري طلب تاجيل سحب ثلاثه الاف جندي من
قوه حفظ السلام التابعه للاتحاد الافريقي
المعروفة باختصارا باتمس مده التاجيل
المطلوبه ثلاثه اشهر للسماح للقوات
المحليه باعاده تنظيم صفوفها ضمن ما جاء
في الرساله اقرار علي الشيخ ان الهجوم
الذي شنه مسلح حركه الشباب في السادس
والعشرين اغسطس الماضي على منطقه
الحكوميه الى الانسحاب من عده بلدات كانت
تحت سيطرتها تحدث عن تحول غير متوقع في
الاحداث كشف نقاط ضعف في الخطوط الاماميه
للقوات الحكوميه كان من المقررين ان تبدا
المرحله الثانيه لسحب قوات ادمس بحلول
الثلاثين من سبتمبر الجاري لخفض عدد
افرادها الى اكثر من اربعه عشر الفا اي
مصير ينتظر الصومال بعد الانسحاب الكامل
لقوات اتمس المقرر نهايه العام المقبل
المده المتبقيه لرحيل اخر جندي اجنبي من
البلاد ليست كافيه لتشكيل الجيش وقوات
الشرطه قويه وقادره على القضاء نهائيا على
حركه الشباب التي تحكم قبضتها على مناطقها
في البلاد
بعثه اتمست تتمتع بتفويض لمحاربه الحركه
التي تابى ان تختفي من المشهد الصومالي
المعقد منذ سنوات طويله الحرب عليها
مستمره وحربها على حكومه مقديش لا تتوقف
وغالبا ما يكون ضحاياها مدنيين عزلا كانوا
في بيوتهم او في فندق او مروا من شارع
حولهم تفجيرا الى اشلاء متى يعرف هذا
البلد السلام الذي فارقه منذ عام 1991
انضموا الينا من مقادير اسماعيل عمر دلمر
المحلل السياسيه والامني سيد اسماعيل ما
تداعيات هذا الهجوم على المواجهه القائمه
بين الحكومه والجماعات المسلحه
شكرا جزيلا لك والاستضافتك هذه تداعيات
تدل ان ضعف قوه حركه الشباب لان دائما
يستهدف الحركه الشباب في
يستهدف على شعب الصومالي ووضعت خسائر
فاضحه خصائص البشريه وماديه جسيمه فهذا لا
يدل ولا يحكم ولا يمكن الشباب ان يسيطر
على هذه البلد من من انفجار وعنف وانما
شعبان يحتاج الى الامن والاستقرار واستهار
حتى يصبح صومالك مثل الدول العالميه يعني
اذا كان حركه الشباب بهذا الضعف كيف هي
قادره على تنفيذ هجمات وان كانت لم تتبنى
هذا الهجوم واذا كانت الحكومه بهذه القوه
لماذا تطلب من الامم المتحده تاجيل سحب
قوات الاتحاد الافريقي
فيه انه الدوله الصوبالي الدوله الفاشله
منذ سقوط الحكومه لكن انتعش الجهاز
الامنيه وكذلك من جانب الاقتصاد ومن كل
الجوانب لان الدوله الصوماليه كانت
خارج المساحه العالميه من جانم الدبلوماس
جمال عسكري الان الحكومه تحسنت عن اجهزه
الامنيه وتحسنت عن اقتصادها فذلك نضرب ان
دول العرب كمثرى صومالي كان نحن في عهد في
عهد
قادم وكل العالم يساعد على الدول الجوار
ومن دول غير الجوار لان الصومالي
هناك يعني ضعف الامن صحيح بالضبط لكن
نحتاج الى يعني نوع من تاجيل هذه القوات
السحب لانه نحن خائف وحكومه المسؤوله عن
امن القومي مسؤول عن امن الشعب الصومالي
والنقابه ما يقع في في
افغانستان بعد اجلاء الامريكيين لكن لا لا
نريد حكومتنا وانما نريد حكومه بتامين
الامن والاستقرار في المواضيض لذا ذلك
حكومه الصومال طلبت بتاجيل من سحاب هذه
القوات
طيب سيد اسماعيل ما هي التحديات التي
تواجهها الحكومه في مواجهتها للجماعات
المسلحه
دائما هذه الجماعه غير عصابه والعصابه
دائما انفجر ما يحتاجونه فمثلا في
الامريكي هي الدوله العظمى الكبيره لها
قدرات الامنيه لها قدرات وتمتلك من
الاسلحه النبويه ولديها يعني ميسانات
كبيره تجاه تحسين المخابرات وجلسه الامنيه
فذلك فمثلا هذه الانفجارات وقعت في كل
مكان حتى في دول الخليج وقعت في دول في
دول اوروبيه لان هذه حركه مثلها خليه
النائمه ولا يمكن تحكيمها في خلي النايم
فنحتاج اشاره نزيد عن دولتنا عن امكانيات
قدرتها العسكريه وقورتها الاجهزه
المخابريه لكي تحسن وتامن الامن الدوله
وتؤمن على
الموارد البشريه وكذلك بتحسين الامن
القومي طيب ولكن الحكومه نفسها في رسالتها
الى الامم المتحده التي تطالب بتاجيل قوات
الاتحاد الافريقي صاحب قوات الاتحاد
الافريقي اعترفت بانتكاسا لجهودها في
مواجه قوه المسلحه
جمعت المسلحه
هذا لا اساس له لا محل له من الاعراب عن
ساحه الصوماليه ومساحه
الشعب الصومالي الصابر وانما هي الحكومه
الصوماليه فضلالي المركزيه لديها قطرات ان
توفير الامن في هذه البلاد اما انسحاب
القوات الافريقيه او تاجيلها فهي
توضع سيضع حكومه
بتجريديا من سحابها او صيضع استراتيجيه
جديدا تجاه هذه القوات الحفظ فمثلا
قوات الحصان لا يشاركون اي حرب انما هم
كانوا فيهم
المقاعد العسكريه لكن لم يشارك في الحروب
والرئيس حسن
هذه البلاد يواجه حربا عالميا وليس لها
هذه التداعيات الشباب ليس خاصا بصوما
وانما هي متوجه في كل عالم في كل الجوار
المصري اثيوبيا وجيبوتي فنحن صوماليين
نحارب هذه الخليه النائبه مستشد الامن
القومي
متوجه في الامن في المنطقه اسماعيل لعمر
دلمره المحلل السياسي والامني
[موسيقى]
افاد مراسل الجزيره بان الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي قصف نقطه رصد تابعه للمقاومه
الفلسطينيه الشرقيه غزه بينما قال جيش
الاحتلال انه استهدف بمسيره موقعا عسكريا
تابع لحركه حماس بالقرب من السياج الحدودي
في قطاع غزه ياتي ذلك عقب قمع قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي مظاهره قرب الحدود
شرقي مدينه غزه ما خلف اصابه عدد من
الشبان الفلسطينيين
اطلقت اللجنه الدوليه لكسر حصار غزه حمله
بعنوان افتحوا موانئ غزه بمبادره من
فلسطينيين خارج ونشطاء للتذكير بالحصار
الاسرائيلي المفروض على قطاع غزه واثاره
على السكان وتجوب الحمله عددا من الموانئ
عبر العالم منها عربيه واوروبيه وتمتد هذه
الحمله لسته ايام تنتهي مع نهايه الشهر
الجاري
انطلقت هذه القوارب من شاطئ غزه
لكنها لن تبتعد كثيرا
فهذا المسير البحري ياتي ضمن حمله دوليه
لكسر حصار غزه بعنوان افتحوا موانئ غزه
حمله على شكل مظاهره بحريه في عدد من
الموانئ في الاردن وقطر وتركيا وبعض الدول
الاوروبيه ينظمها فلسطينيون الخارج لتجديد
الاحتجاج على استمرار الحصار الاسرائيلي
لقطاع غزه وتبعاته ارض غزه ومن ميناء قطاع
غزه المناشدات الفلسطينيه والدوليه لفك
الحصار وجهت بتكريس اسرائيلي له فقطاع غزه
لا توجد فيه الا موانئ متواضعه للصيادين
ومطارها دمره الاحتلال بالكامل منذ سنوات
والمحاولات المتكرره للقوافل البحريه لكسر
الحصار نجحت في مرات قليله بالوصول لشواطئ
غزه وتعمد الاحتلال بعدها منعها بالقوه
اليوم الرساله الاساسيه والاجابه مطلوبه
من المنظمات والمؤسسات الدوليه التي يفترض
بها ان تضع حدا لج الحصار التي غيبت قصرا
اكثر من اثنين مليون و300 الف مواطن داخل
قطاع غزه وغيبت جيلا كاملا عن التواصل مع
العالم الخارجي حمله دوليه للتذكير بمخاطر
استمرار الحصار الاسرائيلي لقطاع غزه
وبضروره ايجاد موانئه للتخفيف من تداعياته
على حياه السكان هنا
فالحصار الذي تفرضه اسرائيل على قطاع غزه
منذ اكثر من 17 عاما زاد الاوضاع
الانسانيه سوءا واضر بجميع القطاعات
المعيشيه من كهرباء وصحه وادى الى تقييد
حركه المواطنين وفاق حجم الخسائر
الاقتصاديه خلال الحصار 17 مليار دولار
يعد الحصار على قطاع غزه جريمه حرب وجريمه
ضد الانسانيه تتطلب موقفا دوليا جدا من
اجل رفعه باعتبار يترك تداعيات كارثيه على
مجمل حاله حقوق الانسان
وما زالت اسرائيل تتمادى في سياساتها
الاحتلاليه رغم القرارات الدوليه
والمطالبات المتكرره بانهاء حصار قطاع غزه
هبه كيلا الجزيره من مدينه غزه
قال وزير الخارجات السعوديه الامير فيصل
بن فرحان ان بلاده سعت لتحقيق الاستقرار
في المنطقه من خلال عقد جولات من
المباحثات مع ايران اضف وزير الخارجات
السعوديه في كلمه امام الجمعيه العامه
للامم المتحده ان هذه المباحثات اسفرت عن
اتفاق بيجين
المملكه الاستقرار المنطقه فقط عقدت جولات
من المباحثات مع الجمهوريه الاسلاميه
الايرانيه استضافتها ثم اسفرت باتفاق بكن
الذي دشن استئناف التمثيل الدبلوماسي
والتواصل المباشر بين البلدين على اساس
الاحترام المتبادله لسياده الدول
واستقلالها وامنها وعدم التدخل في شؤونها
الداخليه واحترام ميثاق الامم المتحده
منظمه التعاون الاسلاميه
هكذا وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل
بن فرحان حرصه بلاده على امنه واستقرار
اليمن ودعم جميع الجهود الرميه الى حل
الازمه
تؤكد المملكه حرصه على امن واستقرار
للجمهوريه اليمنيه الشقيقه ودعم جميع
الجهود الراميه لحل الازمه في اليمن ورفع
علم العادات الانسانيه عن الشعب اليمني
الشقيق والدفع نحو الوصول الى الحلول
السياسيه لاعاده الامن والاستقرار الى
اليمن ودرء التهديد عن المملكه والمنطقه
كما تجدد التاكيد على مبادرتها لانهاء
الحرب في اليمن والتوصل للحل السياسي فعلا
وتدعم الجهود الامويه الدوليه للتوصل الى
حل سياسي وفقا للمرجعيات الثلاث ومنها
قرار مجلس الامن 22 سته عشر
شهدت عده مدن فرنسيه احتجاجات دعت اليها
عشرات الجمعيات والمنظمات النقابيه
والحقوقيه واحزاب سياسيه رفضا لما يصفونه
باستشراء العنف البوليسي وخطاب الكراهيه
ففي باريس خرج متظاهرون في مسيره المناهضه
لما وصفوه بعنف رجال الشرطه والخطاب
العنصري لليمين المتطرف في فرنسا وقد رفعت
شعارات تطالب بالحفاظ على الحريات العامه
والمكاسب الاجتماعيه للشعب الفرنسي كما
اتهم المتظاهرون حكومه الرئيس ماكرون
بالتساهل مع الخطاب العنصري لاحزاب اليمين
ختام الحصاد الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]